I was so nice to this guy when I talked
to him in Pisco's Discord. I was so
insanely nice to him. You have no idea
the level of kid gloves I handled this
dude with. And he's sitting here like
laughing at this guy for getting doxed.
Like I think I think given this stuff,
given Destiny like bragging about doxing
people all over the place, I do think
there's actually a very good reason to
argue that he should be terminated from
YouTube. I think he's mad about getting
doxed.
This is why like honestly these people
this zip zip guy is like actually a
disgusting loser.
>> I think it's esports Batman and Spider
go in.
>> It's a game everybody loves me now cuz
the anti fights,
>> right?
>> Sure they do.
>> Clueless.
>> Well, thanks Josh the Max for the gifted
sub. Quarter mutton tiny at tiny is
almost at 4 million. I'm at 2.2 million.
Yikes.
>> What's up?
>> Oh,
>> holy.
>> So, just why?
>> It's all right.
>> You know, you
>> Oh, go ahead.
>> So, why?
>> That's it. Question.
>> Like, it's just it's so funny the double
standard's like so obvious just from
this. Like, literally Destiny's like,
"Huh, you associate with people who like
associate with people who associate with
people who are mean to me and for that
crime. I have to try to get you doxed
and swatted. I have to dox you so you
can maybe be swatted. I have to do that.
It's like already we've reached a level
where anybody else who's in any of these
communities is gone. Like instantly. Cut
off instantly. Right. Any person who's
not Destiny who's in this like Twitch
ball Jason sphere, they do this. They're
gone. Z.
>> No. No answer. You're You're just going
to sit here.
>> Are you esports Batman?
>> Yes. He knows.
>> Wait, is it?
>> Oh my god. Wait, wait. Is it sports
Batman?
>> What?
>> Oh, you never knew this. Okay, so come
on. I got I got limited time here. Don't
waste it. Why?
>> Why? What?
>> Why did you do me?
>> What? Me? What?
>> Uh, yes. You
>> would I ever do that?
>> Yes.
I I I truly don't understand the Mr.
Mutin guy. Okay. I really actually don't
get it at all. Only in so far as like I
watch him. Somebody sent me a clip the
other day where he's just like, "Don't
these guys all deserve it?" Like,
"Aren't these guys like not worthy of
human consideration at all?" It's like,
"Rener you in this community when
esports Batman was around? Like, didn't
you know some of these didn't you know
like Wicked Supreme, Esports Batman?
Didn't you know some of these people?
Didn't you know like like I I hate to be
like gross, but wouldn't your like wife
had been like friends with a bunch of
the people who had their material
leaked?
I just don't get how you come in and act
like this guy's like cool and awesome.
It's actually really weird. It's super
weird to me. I don't get it. And like I
don't want him cancel. I understand
making the money. That's the argument I
made. You need need money and this is a
lot of money. But like I actually I just
feel like how do you come in and then
you're like actually aggressively going
these people are all scum knowing Yeah.
knowing like
a bunch of the people who had their
material leaked like personally your
wife knowing them
is very weird. I Okay.
>> Like Molina like Molina had her leaked.
I don't Okay.
>> Okay. Yeah. Of course. So come on. Be an
adult. own up to it. Why?
>> I don't know. I have to check my logs.
>> Oh, you don't even know. Okay.
>> Wait, do you have those logs?
>> Yes, I do.
>> Keep asking.
>> I don't know what I'm asking you right
now. Why?
>> Well, I mean, if you have evidence of
those, how do you feel about those uh
emails that Sabre was shooting around?
>> I don't think that I think they were in
good faith, but I think they were a
little bit over the line that I had
nothing to do with them. So
why I'm not concerned about Sabo? I'm
concerned about me. What did I do
specifically?
>> You know 8xes are 50 high qual, right?
>> Dude, so weird. It's just so It's so
bizarre.
>> Okay, that's what I thought. Okay. So
when I have my call later on this
>> Yeah. Like unironically
and like Moot felt like hard done by by
these people. Like he felt hard done by
by a lot of these people. He came back
and he's like just rolling with it. I
It's just It's very weird to me. I don't
know.
>> This afternoon with a couple of people.
You just have no reason.
>> I want I want to be on the record about
this so that I can say I've spoken with
you directly and asked you why.
>> Wait, are you that mad that people
asking you, "Bro, if you care so much,
why don't you do something?"
>> Um,
are you that mad that like you got doxed
and your got posted on Doxin? Are you
that mad? You're that mad about it, bro?
This guy
He's lucky. I was so nice to this guy
when I talked to him in Pisco's Discord.
I was so insanely nice to him. You have
no idea the level of kid gloves I
handled this dude with. Okay. And he's
sitting here like laughing at this guy
for getting doxed, bro. Okay, that's
fine. It's crazy. It's like totally
crazy to me. Well, anything that happens
going forward, I want to let you know
that it's all thanks to you, buddy.
Everything that happens going forward.
>> Yeah, you lit up.
>> Like, I think I think given this stuff,
given Destiny like bragging about doxing
people all over the place, I do think
there's actually a very good reason to
argue that he should be terminated from
YouTube. Probably kicked too. He's like
openly engaging in a doxing campaign
saying he's doing it. I think he should
be banned from both platforms. I don't
think that's wrong to say like that is
that is a level he shouldn't go to
prison but he should be banned from both
platforms after
>> underneath my butt. So I want to thank
you very much by saying put up or shut
up. So I would like to take this
opportunity to recognize your
encouragement and motivation
>> encourage and motivation of of of you.
>> Hello
>> friendly.
>> Hey.
>> So
>> there's a president in here too.
>> Do you have an answer or are you just
going to play quick? Wait, why did you
name yourself esports Batman? Do you
play video games?
>> My answer is I consider every single
person that's acting
wars are crazy. Hold on. You've already
The first sentence you used was
completely moronic, even less. We
haven't doxed anybody. Nobody has been
doxed. Literally, nobody has been doxed.
Nobody has sought to aim public
harassment at a specific person that
makes them feel uncomfortable in real
life. Nobody has done this, right? It's
literally never happened. You can't call
it a war when I'm not doing anything.
When I'm actually I'm not even not doing
anything. I am explicitly saying I
disavow. I do not want this. This is the
opposite of what I want. I don't want
people doxed. I don't want them
pressured in real life. I don't want
that. I want to be able to criticize
people's public public opinions
publicly.
That's it. Right. So, even from the
outset of your sentence here where you
say doxing wars are crazy. There's no
doxing war. Nobody's doxing back.
Nobody's ever doxed back. That's never
happened.
>> Participating in that. Uh
>> there was no precipitating docs that
made him do this. There is no doxing
back after he does it. He is just doxing
people unilaterally until he like killed
his community. It's crazy.
>> Um Discord to be basically the
equivalent of a terrorist. Um I think
that you by giving your absolute legal
advice, most of which has been totally
incorrect and the other parts have
illustrated you can barely read. Um, I
think make you culpable is basically
everything that's going on in that
Discord server. So, suck my dick.
>> So, by commenting on the legal case,
you're culpable for anything anybody in
that discord server does. Totally
leaving out the fact that nobody knew
about Cyber stuff until like when it got
leaked essentially. I knew he'd reached
out to Rose, but I thought that was a
totally like one-sided or uh like back
and forth.
And I was like, well, that's weird, but
I I don't know. He's not he's not like
using the community to do it. He's not
doing anything crazy. It's like, that's
weird. That's [__] up.
Great. Thank you. That's all I needed to
hear.
>> Have fun. Be careful.
>> Wow. Did their voice defend himself? So,
really?
>> Yeah. I think he started. Just kidding.
Are you coming? Let's go.
>> Yeah. So, you left here.
>> Um, yeah. I'm going to the apartments.
>> All right. Let's go.
>> Yeah. They kind of dodged the
>> He's suing, I think. Uh, I think what's
going to happen is I would imagine
esports Batman and everybody should just
go after Destiny's platforms, right, who
are doxing.
Like I think I think I should actually
go to like the kickstaff and be like,
"Hey, here's all the evidence of this
guy admitting multiple times to doxing
all these people." He makes up that I've
had some hand in it or I've done
something back to him or that something
like untoward has happened because of
me. Literally no ev no literally no
evidence of it. He's going to keep doing
it. I don't think it's healthy to have
him on these platforms and to advocate
for doxing more people on these
platforms. I do think he should be
banned. I think he should be
demonetized. I don't think he should be
doing this with like I don't think he
should have a platform where he's making
money off of this. It's actually pretty
over. Kicks out the exemplars of
morality. I'm pretty sure they're still
pretty badly against doxing.
>> Does he play video games? Question.
>> He knew he was going to get owned.
That's why he
>> implying that he's going to sue. I
guess.
>> Oh, I don't. No, I I think probably just
going after the platforms is the good
choice. I think I think YouTube given
what has already happened to him on
YouTube would consider terminating him
over this 100%. Right. I never, by the
way, don't want anybody to make anything
up. Just want to take the explicit
admissions of guilty conduct, right? And
just say, "Yeah, I think I think this
YouTube channel is un like you can't
have this." They do moderate offplatform
stuff.
>> Good for him.
>> That was the implication. Yeah. I don't
think you can
>> for getting doxed.
I mean, Kiwi Farms would go down then,
right?
>> Shrimple.
>> Those people are anonymous.
>> Kiwi Farms gets subpoenaed for private
for people's information, but it's very
difficult to go after somebody
anonymous. Destiny's not anonymous. I do
think, by the way, somebody pointed this
out that uh trying to crowdfund a
lawsuit to go after him for this for
harassment would just be good on its
face.
Um there are harassment laws that you
can sue under. friends $3.
>> I don't mind chilling and waiting a bit
to see how things go,
>> but Modmail doesn't work since I'm not
in the server, though. Just an FYI.
>> Okay. Uh, I'll try to figure it out at
some point. Yeah, it's a little Yeah,
exactly. He's He's admitting like bad
intent on the Pisco stream. He's
admitting bad intent. He's literally
saying, "I did it." He's posting it
himself. He's not denying it anywhere.
Perfectly happy to take culpability for
it. I do think there are real ways you
could sue somebody for this where you
can prove their specific like malice.
He's explicitly doing this to try to
like destroy my business, right? That's
got to be there's got to be a bunch of
there. No, that's what he's admitting to
here, right? He's talking about
destroying my community, destroying the
uh the Jtock Discord server. That's like
going after my business, right? I'm sure
there's a hundred different ways a
lawyer could think of how to sue
somebody over this, but we'll see. Who
knows? He actually got that mad that
everyone was telling him, "Bro, you
obviously don't care about this. Shut
the up."
>> I think he's mad about getting doxed.
This is why like honestly these people,
this Zip Zip guy is like actually a
disgusting loser. Like having him in
your community is a huge indictment of
your community. I think you
like the the parasites who are like,
"Oh, no, you should be able to dox
people." There's no there's no large
difference between DGG these people and
who will who will advocate for totally
cataclysmic negative action from Destiny
with no reason. No, they do the
defensive doxing thing. They can't prove
anybody is culpable for the the doxes
they're putting out. Right. The people
they dox aren't culpable for the things
that they're upset about at all. Destiny
is directly culpable for what esports
Batman is upset about. You see the
difference?
>> No, I do care, guys. I do care.
>> I He's so lucky. He's so lucky. I didn't
uh I didn't watch this first. Holy [__]
All this talk and he said he was neutral
and wick. Yeah, he's just a liar.
They're just liars, dude. It's nuts. I'm
going to make so many calls later.
>> Well, I mean, they came in so
aggressive. I thought that it was like a
troll. I was like, why? I was like,
>> yeah, I didn't realize.
>> Yeah.
>> Uh there's another opport there's
another possibility here. It's possible
that Mutin is like just concerned that
by sitting outside Destiny's sphere of
influence, by not directly operating in
favor of him, he will be put on the
terrorist watch list at some point in
the near future. Right. His wife did
retweet that Substack. Has Pichu
apologize for retweeting Pixie substack?
Hey, Mr. Moon. Has has Pikachu
apologized for that? I feel like she
should probably start cooking up Pixie
should apologize for the Substack,
right? Shouldn't Pikachu apologize for
retweeting it and amplifying it and
amplifying all of Destiny's victims?
That was probably a wrong thing to do,
right?
>> I thought there was somebody I thought
it was a voice trainer was gonna do. I
have to stop watching this. I I I'm
going to skip forward to the spider bit.
>> Is it for just like like this just just
like um disagreements or just like or or
what? Like
>> Yeah, just because they disagree with my
opinion. I think
>> that must be it, bro.
>> Yeah, I think it's because they
basically been long like long-term
stalking and harassing me and people
around me for Yeah. about a year now.
It's been I think it's pretty
relentless. It's pretty insane. And when
it's got to the
>> Oh, wait. Is it harassing in the same
way that you harass Hassan? Was Hassan
correct in everything he said that you
guys like follow Hassan? Your community
watches him constantly a logs everything
he says in his Discord. Constantly
provides it to other content creators so
that Hassan could be further harassed.
Is that harassment? I'm like I'm like
doubleA baseball version of the Yankee.
Okay. Like Destiny's the Yankees. DG's
the Yankees of harassing someone in the
exact way he's describing. Like right.
I'm like double A baseball.
I like there's a whole other level of
that I could take it to before I get
anywhere near Destiny's League. Okay.
How am I materially different from what
they do?
Is that lying about being harassed? He's
describing what you you could say cuz
harassment is just subjective basically.
You could say this is harassment, right?
But I'm I'm telling you it is far less
than what Dan and Destiny have done to
Hassan. It's like 1 1,000th of what D
and Destiny have done to Assan.
How many people is Assan doxed?
Quick question. How many people is
doxed? Oh, it's like zero.
>> Where that Saba guy is literally
bragging about emailing like a victim in
my court case and is and everybody in
that server is like clapping along.
>> What is she What is she a victim of?
What is she a victim of?
>> And laughing at it is Yeah, I think it's
I'm good on that. Chief,
>> I I would want anybody if anybody could
argue. Like, if anyone hears that
argument, if you're watching this on
YouTube and you want to go back to it,
bro, step in. Like, I understand why
some people might not like it, but I
just don't get why anyone acts like it's
like so evil. Like, it was just clearly
like a totally evil act. And then cuz I
would accept if like somebody from my
community want to come in and go like,
"I can't morally accept this at all that
that like Cyber is allowed to stay." I
would understand you're applying a
standard, right? But it's DJers who are
totally disingenuously applying a
standard they don't believe it. Crazy.
>> You said you had a couple questions.
That was one.
>> Oh yeah. Uh like would you ever like uh
we came to the bridge with the JCO or
something or what or no? Or just like
over
>> maybe if he's like suicidal and he needs
like supplies, but otherwise no.
>> Oh,
>> that's that's true. That's just that's
mutual.
>> Um do you think um
Shut the G? I [__] hate you. Do you
think um you kind of overreacted of like
by like doxing a couple of people inside
the Jag community a little bit?
>> No.
>> No, they I don't think they have like
I'm I'm not trying to like downplayers,
but like I don't think they cause you
like physical harm, right? I don't think
it.
>> Okay. I don't think I caused them
physical harm, did I?
>> Not that I'm aware of. No.
>> No. Well, then we're good. Triple ass. I
I don't think I don't think like
>> Spider is so
uh he's just so
>> I don't think I don't think like this
having disagreements like you know like
them getting doxed though low key
>> you what
>> I I don't think like having
disagreements over you know certain
reason or certain situations
like justify um them getting docked like
>> wow that's a brave position. You don't
think disagreeing with people on the
internet is reason to get docks? That's
a good one dude. True. I know. Sure.
>> Then why are they doxing?
>> Okay, so this fat won't actually
this guy. Oh, this guy. I disavow. I
apologize for what I just said, but holy
[__] this guy.
Why is he Why is he going to say that
this happening? It's not happening. It's
not happening. It's literally not
happening. Show me any evidence of this
happening. Any evidence that I had
anything to do with it that I didn't
disavow it. When this guy had bad happen
to him, when people would say, "Oh, this
guy's a loser. You should go after him."
I always defended him every time him and
his wife and now he's going to totally
lean into this cuz he can make money.
You're a [__] loser. You have no idea
what you're talking about. You can't
actually you can't actually show
anything you're going to allege and you
go and suck the of this predator because
you are a fat loser.
Okay? You and your wife have you are
insubstantial soulless drains. Okay? And
the reason you're back in Destiny's
community is because society has deemed
you as such and you have no other way to
make money. Okay, good luck
when when everything when when
everything's said and done. Good luck.
>> Jake, this is triggering.
>> I get triggered because I actually gave
this guy the benefit of the doubt so
many times. And I do that every single
time. Every single time. Okay. And I
just get shown what people these people
are. Every single time I give the
benefit of the doubt to Arerodite. I
give the benefit of the doubt to
counterpoints. I give the benefit of the
doubt to mutin and his wife. Every
single time I'm the for acting like
these people have a single ounce of
calcium left in their spines every
single time. It's such a joke.
>> The ro family check where the I don't
know. I know I don't know where to get
the information the rose information
from that.
>> I didn't know that. I just You're
telling me now for the first time. But I
haven't seen like maybe my blind [__] I
haven't seen like the J community like
docs like any other like DG though.
>> They don't need to. Every doc is posted
on Kiwi Farm. So they actively
collaborate with then why would they dox
anybody just
>> way actively collaborate with? Okay.
Show me active collaboration. Where's
the active collaboration? Careful. His
wife isn't. His wife gets on the
streams. What the [__] are you talking
about? That'd be stupid. Do you have
like this is the one who gave the docs
information of Rose to Kiwi Farms.
How are these people so brain damaged?
How are these people so brain dead? She
talks about you. She hops on the stream.
She's part of the content. Moon's doing
content on this every day. You think
they don't understand? You think they
don't talk about it? What do you think?
No, no, no, no, no. I don't think, by
the way, all that said, I'm angry
because I give these people the benefit
of the doubt. I go, "Oh, well, here's
like a totally innocent thing and
they're just going to make their money
and they're then they're going to move
on, right?
They're just going to make their money,
but they're not going to get like
involved. And then this guy helps spread
lies, and I'm like, "Oh, actually,
this loser." No, Pikachu didn't do the
same thing. But [__] this loser. Okay.
Uh, also, obviously, same rules as
always apply. You don't go after these
people. You don't talk to them. You
don't like reach out to them. You don't
do Okay. Obviously,
I'm venting because I just I continually
try to give people the benefit of the
doubt in this area and they fail me in
in like um totally like immoral ways
every single time. I'm just like, "Do
the right thing, dude. Do the [__] right
thing. Just call it out. Just call out
the behavior." And they're all It's like
It's just the Trump thing. It's like a
cult. It's crazy.
>> Any like confirmation that like
>> Jason?
Nope. I'm too stupid. I made that all
up. They're too smart for me. I can't. I
think I just made all of that up.
>> He's literally smiling. This ugly fat is
smiling.
Look at his face. Look at his face with
this disgusting pubic hair on his chin.
>> Gross, dude.
>> Okay.
>> Do you have any confirmation that I do
any of them?
>> Uh, I seen I seen some screenshots from
the in the
shot.
>> You sure?
>> Yep.
>> Pause.
>> Literally.
>> Yep.
>> Literally. Do you do you have proof that
Yeah. Everybody's proof? Yes.
To show face to do all this? No, I
don't. This man is ugly in a vacuum. He
is disgusting in a vacuum. He is melted
ice cream in a vacuum. Okay. I can say
whatever the I want.
>> N you're mean, bro.
>> I'm not meaning. They're fake. That's
fake.
>> N you're mean, bro. You
>> think I would dock somebody, bro? That's
like the same as somebody.
>> Bro, you're a liar right now.
>> Are you serious? Positive 100%.
>> Shrimple ass. Shrimple.
>> Shrimple ass.
>> When when these people have no skill set
by which they can operate in the world
and they're trying to convince you,
okay, some year three three years down
the line that they didn't really know
what Destiny was doing. They did they
didn't really know. He like kind of
convinced. They're just lying. Okay.
They're just lying. Everybody in that
orbit just lying the whole time. They're
all lying. They're a bunch of liars.
Okay.
God,
I still have things I could talk about
with these people that would just be
super uncomfortable. Super uncomfortable
conversations that I keep to myself cuz
I'm uh
>> Wait, can I ask you something? Have
y'all seen Jacob dox anyone? Well,
besides all Rose, I don't know those
Rose.
>> Besides that one.
>> Oh, no. Destiny is the one who dox Rose.
Destiny is the one who dox Rose. We
didn't dox Rose. Caba talked to Rose.
didn't publish any of that information
publicly obviously,
>> right? The victim.
>> Yeah. I mean I mean like I mean like
that's kind of weird. I don't know. You
should like email like the family. It's
kind of word. Um
shmple as my friend.
>> Let's go to that location.
>> I haven't seen like
>> Oh, it's not information that would go
against Destiny.
So people who prop him up. People prop
him up. What do
>> you mean like other examples of like
doxing like you or
>> spider? Spider is just like so low IQ.
It's very funny.
>> At this point, actually, I just I don't
care what happens to any of these
communities. Like, Peace Co included. I
think that all you guys are weird and
need to be wiped from the internet. I
think it's all like gotten way out of
hand. I'm like, at this point, I don't
give a [__] about any of it. Shremble.
>> Coer, just a quick update. Destiny had
to go over some of these logs and stuff
in real time and couldn't do it. Hold
on. Let me go find this real quick. Let
me find out what I sent real quick. Real
quick, real quick. Where are these logs?
Sorry. I also I regret saying the slur.
Okay, I regret saying the slur not
because it wasn't appropriate, but
because I regret how it affects other
people. Okay, the logs. Yeah, he
basically got like confronted on these.
And he goes, there's no evidence here
that I that I kept. It's like this is by
the way like the third time he's being
asked about it. Like, bro, you let your
you let me know your you still have
videos saved your computer. You knew it
was alleged that she was underage. You
still have them. Do you see how this is?
That's like on its face just obvious you
have. It's really up that you're telling
me this. And Destiny doesn't go, "No, I
don't have you misunderstood me." He
goes, "I don't even know 100% of her age
is legitimately less than 18 when these
were taken." If you don't have, why are
you like saying why it might not be?
Yeah. What are these when these were
taken? Cuz he also said, "Oh, I wasn't
talking about like a video." Wait, what
would it be? Why would it be a problem
if she was legitimately under 18 when
quote unquote these were taken? And then
number two, I'm pretty sure I still have
an obligation to preserve stuff related
to my court case. I've talked about this
with my lawyer already, specifically
with regards to the Rose stuff. Oh.
Oh, to be honest, what we should do is
actually start a Twitter campaign to get
this in the hands of JD Vance. I think
that's the appropriate play. Start
clipping this stuff up. Start showing
the logs. Get somebody to post a video.
Get that blowing up on YouTube. Okay. Of
all of this stuff with the explicit idea
of getting JD Vance, getting it in JD
Vance's hands. Hey JD, this is like open
and shut, buddy. This is open and shut.
Cash would [__] it up. Oh no. Well,
we'll wait until Cash is fired and then
we'll we'll re-evaluate. Okay, that is a
good point though. JD sucks. Give it to
Don Jr. What kind of excuse could he
possibly say? My guess he misremembered
and thought he had but realized HE
DIDN'T. NO, THAT WOULD HAVE BEEN A
BETTER EXCUSE. COER. He sat there trying
to explain how none of these messages
mean one iota that he retains. That
would have been A GOOD LIE. THAT WOULD
HAVE BEEN A WAY BETTER LIE. He actually
just tried to gaslight everybody and say
that these logs don't mean anything. The
these are not the logs you're looking
for. He tried to do a Jedi mind trick.
Okay, that's the sad thing. And three,
if something were to come of this, I
don't know if I'd want to wipe
everything and not have something to
turn over to the authorities. As in he's
a white hat, guys. White hats. White
hats enjoyer. Okay, guys. What if the
What if the cops do want to look into
this? Shouldn't I hold on to the child?
Like, they're all pertaining to if
Willie was correct. Like, Willie is
saying this is C. And he's like, well, I
don't know for sure. It's And I do want
to I do want to retain it just in case.
And he went with no no no. I don't I
don't actually I really, really, really
don't actually I didn't mean this was at
all. It's crazy.
if hype. Dude, the best the funniest
part about this is Willie is like so
Willy's like so low IQ that the Destiny
community managed to like sigh up him
into thinking he might have gotten this
wrong. That's like almost funnier than
Destiny's defense is that Willie is like
so low IQ. He's so without his own
internal monologue that he was convinced
that he was actually wrong for this for
like posting this for being upset about
it for calling like he convinced himself
he was wrong. Like he might be wrong.
It's like dude that is crazy.
You could absolutely do that to Willie.
Yeah, I do believe that. Yeah, I think
you could totally convince Willie if you
had enough Twitter clout. You could
convince Willie that it's flat like in a
day. in a day and a half tops. Anyway,
it's some goofy action. Okay. Some very
goofy action.
>> Wait, Spider, are you guys way too
comfortable talking [__] and being
weird? Is stalking, harassing people?
>> It's kind of weird.
>> So, Spider, are you a loner box editor?
>> No, I'm the clipper. The clip guy.
Clipper.
>> Okay. Uh, somebody said to ask, "How do
you feel about spreading bad empanada
dog saying water box?"
>> That's pretty dog [__] happens to
pretty weird.
>> Oh. Oh, interesting. Okay.
>> Oh, interesting.
>> J just something I wanted to ask. That's
interesting.
>> Okay.
>> I mean, like I don't have a stake in
this. What's a observer, bro? I'm I'm
looking at from both sides. Okay. Oh,
both sides. Neutral. Both sides. Very
neutral.
Did Willie Mack walk back the video? No,
he said I think he said something along
the lines of
>> um if I was wrong I'll apologize when
everything's said and done but like I
something along those lines.
>> Very neutral.
>> I think so.
>> I have no beef for any side neutral.
>> I don't
>> I don't think like am I trying to like
do that
>> you think bad wasn't I think bad but was
posting doc's. He was posting like he
would like false sue somebody, get a
false police report filed and then he
would publish the information. That's
oxy. Come on, ma'am. Come on, man.
>> I get it. Maybe because of like what
they say is kind of maybe it might be
unhinged about like the whole like
court, but I don't think it's like
justified docs, you know, like what if
she thinks zip?
>> What do you think? Zip zip.
>> Wait, sorry, I didn't hear what was the
question.
>> Do you think that like what Destiny said
was like Yeah, you know what?
Okay. of like if they disagree if they
uh say unhin [__] or disagree with me on
like uh on like the whole court
situation or any other stuff in general
they deserve to get dogs like you don't
think that's a little bit crazy
>> no that's what he said
>> I don't think that's what he said at all
that anybody who disagrees with dogs I
think you're right that you think that's
what he said
>> he said anybody agreeing in those
discords right sorry he didn't even say
that he said anybody be associating
those escores getting doxed.
>> It's mo voice changer. Uh oh,
>> I might be. Could I could be? Maybe. Who
knows?
>> I think basically his opinion is like
all these anti fan communities have
gotten so out of hand and crazy that he
just doesn't give what happen give a
[__] what happens anymore.
>> Okay.
>> But like doesn't that give like more
>> Oh my god. Doesn't that justify them?
Doesn't that make what they're saying
true and right?
I mean, again, there's a reason Destiny
went to doxing instead of just pulling
up clips of me and saying where I was
wrong and why I was wrong, right?
There's a reason he went to doxing
instead of doing that. Well, he cut
against the entirety of the Ke's
manifesto to do it.
>> Actually, no. Actually, you know,
actually, you know, one time I was like
raping this girl and she was like, "Oh
my god, stop." And then she hit me and I
was like, "When you smack me as I'm
Doesn't that kind of justify me doing
this? I'm kind of proving my point when
I I'm trying to do one time I was
stabbing this guy with a knife like 20
times and he punched me in the nose and
I was like when you punch me is that
kind like justify me stabbing you
>> like that?
>> No, it's not like that. Um
>> Oh, there's nothing like that. Okay.
>> God, it's unfortunate cuz I again I
pulled away. I wasn't covering this
stuff as much
and this guy just had to start going
after people again in the Discord. He's
like just made it clear that it's my
community or his community. Probably
both in the end. But if that's if he
wants people like motivated to like
actually
get justice for this as in like actually
go to some form of of authority, report
it, seek whatever monetary or like
whatever penalties we can put on him.
Again, through official means through
these platforms, through uh the law. I'm
definitely going to pursue the law thing
now. I I thought it was pointless, but I
don't think it's pointless. I think it
actually has a purpose now. So, I'm glad
I'm glad that some people have brought
it up.
>> Eat rapology gum.
>> My bad.
>> It probably gives like Jac
M.
>> How? What?
>> Probably gives like Jacock and his
community more ammo. No. Or
>> I'm sorry, I couldn't hear you. I was a
robot up.
>> It probably gives JC and his community
more ammo.
>> Really? I thought a few people left the
server once people started getting
docks. That's what I saw.
>> Like just kind of giving away what his
actual motive is, right?
>> Curious. I also know that certain people
were given immunity
>> from doxing.
>> Oh, like who?
>> Cuz they were engaged in bad behavior.
>> You weren't banned in the JAC meeting.
>> They were what?
>> You weren't banned in the JAC.
>> The [__] is immunity from
>> being doxed? Oh, it's not immunity. You
guys are the ones who aren't operating
in like a liberal way, right? It's not
immunity. You have just decided as the
dictator who's shooting people in the
head who say anything bad about you that
you're going to some cute girl in the
head. That's all that's happened here.
>> By people who would want to do Jay sucks
for members.
>> I don't really understand what you're
saying.
I mean, I have 52K this run.
>> I've got 44 lucky.
>> Yeah. Can you restate it?
>> A few Yeah. A few people were given
immunity from being
>> he's saying that basically uh so they're
explicitly trying to dox people in my
community to try to get people to leave
my community
and they are explicitly
dude they're explicitly saying well but
actually like if you argue on behalf of
Destiny in that discord maybe you could
maybe you could stay and just like not
you get immunity you get immunity I
guess apparently I've never heard of
this concept immunity from the doxing
we've given immunity to a couple members
>> for being in the Jubile server.
>> Oh, okay.
>> So, it wasn't just it wasn't just
>> I don't think that's
>> I'm ready to
>> and train out. [__] up.
>> Let's go.
>> Is your inventory full?
>> Bro, what?
>> Oh, like you can hold a lot of stuff or
a little stuff?
>> You can hold like five things, six
things.
>> Jesus.
>> Sorry. Go ahead.
>> No, I'm just listening to Zip Zip.
>> What is it?
>> Some bullshitter got [__] for getting
knocked. So,
>> yeah. that the robot.
>> But did the people who who got docks or
whoever got immunity did crazy or
something or what? Um
>> people immunity did that's why they
immunity.
Don't catch. Don't hit them with
hit. Simple as
>> Hello.
Spider.
>> Whatever, bro.
>> Uh, what did they think?
>> Uh, yeah. He's um, but that's fine.
Listen,
apparently
apparently they learned nothing from
Israel. Okay.
pushing people until they have like no
other choice but to like do whatever
they can to survive. Usually not a good
idea. Okay. And again, I'm going to
stick to the rules. I'm going to report
him in the ways I can to the places I
can. I've never done it before, by the
way. I've never reported him for
anything. But like this is just clear.
It's like clear what we're doing here,
right? It's crazy.
>> About
that doesn't work. Um, I've already got
a couple DMs. It's good. Whatever this
is, I He is changing people's minds,
right? Being this brazen about it, he is
changing people's minds. I'm already
getting DMs. Okay, stop vague posting.
I'm getting DMs from people who work at
platforms and are like, "Hey, I work
here. I do this. Um, if you want to put
something together, that kind of thing."
Which is good cuz that's actually the
thing that kind of prevented me from
before from doing it before, right? was
not having like contacts in
>> Hassan. If he spreads the docks of Lorok
or uh other people from PE progressive
victory, does that justify him getting
dogs?
>> I don't really give a [__] about. Okay.
I mean like I don't care if he gets
dogs. I don't care.
>> Hassan Hassan. I mean like technically
he didn't like he kind of like I don't
give a [__] I don't care. So
>> it's it we can we can do Kasan for
doxing loner box and uh other people
right?
>> Yeah for him.
>> Okay. And uh JTO JTO supporting doxers
and
them being part of his community and
>> no evidence of this at all. Certainly
not at a level that could to justify
anything like this. Right. So, I'll
never say that there's no never been
anybody doxed in my community because
there's not a single online community
where that's the case. Like seriously,
why are we why are we pretending that
this is a bar anybody can meet? This
again is just a careful manifesto
standard. I can't prevent anonymous
people from doing random [__] in my
community. I can moderate it, right? I
can moderate it if it happens. If you
are aware of it happening and you want
to report it to me, I will take action.
I have rules against it. You literally
get banned automatically if you post
links to Kiwi Farms in my Discord.
Remember when he cut off Nick because
some guy who's streaming to Uncosy to 75
guys said to report Mr. Girl. Oh, we're
way past that. We're way past that.
Coer. Yeah, I know. He's a total He's
just a total liar, man.
>> Being posted his community also
justifies his community getting dogs.
Oh,
>> I mean like some like specific doxers
like who like like who do like who?
>> The the whole community they they
support it just same way Husan supports
the docking.
>> Yeah, but like doin who? Like who?
Destiny what your the DG?
>> Yeah. Yeah, sure. DJs people involved
with the case.
>> Do people in have like the Jaw community
um doxed them or
>> what
>> or did do the people you said DG got
doxed by the Jaw community? Like I'm
saying I'm asking like does DGG
currently have like screenshots of like
the Jaw community doxing him or what?
>> They support it same way Hassan supports
about other doxing people.
>> Yeah. He says no that's actually totally
false. Totally disavow doxing. Totally
disavow that puts somebody in fear of
their real life safety. Right. Anything
like that you there's obviously a huge
gap between you just being like this
guy's a fat loser and straight up doxing
somebody trying to post any info you can
to get them hurt. Right. Like obviously
there's a massive difference. Obviously
>> support I'm asking like who like like is
there any screenshots from the DG
community
>> having screenshots of the Jaw community?
>> Uh I think there's uh evidence that they
support them not that they directly do
it but same way Hassan doesn't.
>> So evidence they support them. So that's
a totally subjective standard you've
invented. Now show me the evidence that
they support that we support doxing. I
actually, dude, it's crazy. Bears
repeating the Kevl manifesto where he
talks about KF getting undue hate and
hints at Doc's bin. Yeah. Okay, hold on.
So, is this going to be the website zero
section? We can look over right now. We
should watch this whole thing again on
stream. Think that what happens is, so
here's kind of what happens. Kiwi Farms
is the most visible site on the internet
that does harassment, but there's a lot
of other things that exist in the
background that are arguably responsible
for more. And none of those websites are
ever brought up because there's no glory
in chasing those websites. People want
to slay the dragon. They want to get
Kiwi Farms. Um, but Kiwi Farms basically
ends up taking the fall or getting the
blame for literally everything. Even
though
>> Wow. So, are they like not that bad?
>> Um,
>> you saying my Discord's like dox?
>> Even though a lot of the stuff like the
Uber Eats hacks, like the swattings and
the doxings, like there was that one
swatting that didn't even happen. The
person emailed me and told me that they
called the police. Um, I just don't
think it's right that like Kiwi Farms is
getting like the blame for every single
bad set on the internet.
>> No, tipped $5.
>> Greetings J. Le Kadima Achi Koha Shell
Arts Ha Nich.
>> Thank you very much for the five. Ben
Shapiro should get nuked off the
internet for doxing. Um, fine, but like
it has to be for doxing. like um it
can't be made up other you can't
attribute and like so like you can't
take things that they didn't do and
attribute it to the person you want to
hurt. Like you can't you can't try to go
for like one specific person and then
take actions from other sources and
attribute it to that person with no
link, no obvious causal link at all.
like you're kind of applying liberal
principles here where somebody's like
innocent until proven guilty and you
need to actually have a causal link
between them and some harm before you
can actually go after them like that.
The problem that I have too is that
Serenti like Serenti obviously knows in
the background that this other site
exists because she's trying to get other
people not to talk about it and then
she's constantly and consistently
blaming Kiwi Farms for stuff that the
other website is doing. Dude, it's crazy
how badly he just became Keles like in
every possible way.
like down to Keel's obsession with
trying to dox other people after it
happened to him. Like the exact same
thing, bro. He's got to get that boob
job before he runs out of money. Okay?
He's got to get those triple D's before
he runs out of money. Just saying.
You don't want to you don't want to risk
you don't want to risk one of those
airate bots jobs. Okay.
>> But um yeah, for future people to reach
out to you directly that might now be
concerned about future leaks, is there
any particular reason you leaked the Bob
posting messages? Um cuz I think that
her and um Keville are sketchy as both
of them. So what do we learn about the
DIY HRT site? Ke's lying isn't a new
phenomenon. Clay was open about homebrew
as was on the site itself.
All right. All right, dude. It's crazy.
That's It's so wrong to attribute these
things to kiwi farms. Even Kiwi farms
when they didn't do them. It's so up
that you can't You're going after them,
but not for their real behavior. Oh,
what is Destiny doing? going after my
community, but not for their behavior.
Not anything. The Kyla peace out. I
don't know. She took like a month off
again, but she's been DMCAing Riyle. So,
I assume she's there doing
>> that whole sec.
>> I think she's if she would just like
reach out and be like, "Hey, cuz I don't
know what her problem is with the
content, like Riyle's content." But
she's been DMCAing Riyle and being like,
"I'm going to keep DMCing you unless you
take all the content of me down." So,
that's cool. But I do think it might
have to do with the thumbnails.
I feel like if you just reach out like
the thumbnails are up, don't do the
thumbnails. I would get it, right? Like
I I would I would say Ry, you shouldn't
do the thumbnails. Ry, don't do the
don't do the thumbnails. I get that
everyone likes fat Arerodite. They think
it's funny, but don't do the thumbnails.
It's kind of it's mean, but like if it's
like the the the content itself is
transformative and if Aerodite is like
that concerned about it. If we're going
to do Aerodyite content in the future,
we'll just clip it, right? Like I'm
fully committed to doing Aerodyite
content whenever whenever she says
something. Fully committed to doing it
at any point in the future. Okay, Ry,
stop posting a unedited. No, no, no, no,
no, no. She gets edited and it gets made
to look fat and it's like I get how that
would be frustrating. I get it. I would
not extend that to probably anybody
else. But for every day, she's like
described body image issues like
whatever. Could do not do fat. But like
you can't DMCA transformative content
or if she's going to. I do believe
it's it's time to actually stand up
business on that. Okay, you should. I
can't tell Ra what to do. You should
though.
>> Felt like a shot with no tracer. Well,
Chloe says that she's never
>> It's like the same that happened to
Beckett with KP though, right? It's like
the exact same.
>> Plugged anything related to homebrew.
She's spamming it at me right now in
DMs. She's never had anything to do with
>> Oh, why am I still watching this? We
don't care about this. I don't think I
care about this anymore either. I'll
watch it till Spider
>> people, but he supports about other
indoxing people and he spreads the
ducks.
>> Like what? Kiwi Farms like Jac supports
like the JS community supports like Kiwi
farmers or or what?
>> They they share the thread. They talk
about the like the epic meme
>> that he's making things up. There might
be references to Blav, but I mean Blav
has honestly
like wreaked havoc in that community
almost as much as he's wreaked it in
DGG.
So like but yeah, you get autobed for
the links and you have been for months
and months and months from before
Destiny was like saying that we were
like Kiwi farmers or something. That's
so crazy, man.
>> Who dogs people, they support them. They
post like screenshots from there.
>> This is just not This is like explicitly
not true. Like he's just explicitly
lying again. And then they go, "Oh,
well, you closed your Gen Chat." Because
somehow, and I don't know how this
happened with Destiny advocating uh mass
harassment on my community, but somehow
people were getting reported for
literally everything,
right? Like literally I got reported for
saying, "Uh, oh man, Vos review today."
question mark that got reported for
child safety.
So, I just closed all of the old general
chat because I think the messages get
tagged in some way that they like were
said when the chat wasn't 18 plus. So, I
switched the chat to 18 plus. I archived
the old gen chat and then I put a new
gen chat in cuz I didn't want people to
keep getting banned for nothing. But
like that's a response to legitimate
harassment. So
>> they they like uh giggle when someone uh
gets uh harassed by them. They celebrate
whenever some one gets
>> Example example example. Okay.
>> There was the laughing at the Rose
thing, but that was laughing. I laugh
because Destiny doxed her himself and
proved that he'd been a minor been
exchanging material with a minor through
a proxy.
Right. That's
that's what actually happened. someone
gets knocked like a like like from like
the DG committee or like any other
content creator.
>> Yeah, like uh like uh people around
Destiny.
>> But to be fair, that's not because
people are psyched Rose got doxed. What
that is is Destiny saying that it's a
Kiwi Farm skitso theory, that she's 17,
that she's a minor, that everybody's
lying who says it. Right. That was
Destiny who said that. Uh everybody's
making that up. When they reference this
girl, they don't care. They They're just
making that up. It's a lie. It's a lie.
It's a lie. And then he's he literally
doxes her because I don't know why
apparently to find out who leaked this
was what he said today.
And
that cuz that makes sense when you have
her name and her face in her school and
her major. That definitely makes sense.
But regardless of how stupid that is, he
docked her himself and proved she was
17. Proved that she was a minor when she
was exchanging material with him. We
don't actually believe it. This was an
elaborate elaborate catfish. Do we? So,
it could have been a catfish in that I
might be led to believe or I might
believe that the solo person did the
lion share of this messaging. Maybe,
maybe, maybe.
I don't really believe it because like I
said, I just don't think there's any way
where Yeah. I I don't see any universe
where she is taking like a picture of
some dude that looks like Destiny to
send to him, right? Yeah. It doesn't
really matter for Destiny's actions.
Sure. But I don't believe it's some
elaborate catfish. No, it changes
nothing for Destiny's culpability as we
discussed with that guy earlier.
>> People like Dan Hitch Dan's wife.
Wait,
>> well, hold on. It also the fact that she
was 17 also totally explodes the implied
consent argument, right?
He can't argue implied consent because
Pixie knew Molina might see it and so
therefore she knew a bunch of people
might see it. There's no way he thought
he had implied consent for an 18
so-called 18-year-old sex worker that
he'd known for a week that he just
started DMing. Right? There is no
universe where he could argue that he
thought he had implied consent in that
case. And nobody will ever hold this
guy. They just never hold him
accountable for his previous lies.
Right? So he's lied the whole time. The
whole timeline is just nothing but lies.
He He tried to dox me. He posted a bunch
of other docs before Rose was doxed,
before any of the things that he's
saying justifies the docks. And now he's
reversing it. Right? He's he's running
backwards in time
and using actions that he couldn't have
possibly known about, that he had no
idea about, right? That hadn't yet come
to pass and he's justifying the previous
doxing. It makes no sense. And this fat
ugly loser just sits here smirking and
nodding.
>> Yeah. Wife got docks on Q farms and like
what Jason can be celebrated or to show.
Yeah.
>> Nope. And I don't think Dan would even I
don't think Dan would say that. I think
I think Dan would say that that is
wrong. And he knows that's wrong. Dan
knows for a fact that as much of a
problem as I have with him, I've
explicitly never said anything bad about
his wife or his kids and I'd said it's
insane. Even though I think he is a
person who wants to dox people, who
looks to dox people, who's facilitated
doxing people, even in spite of that,
I've said it's insane to think about
going after his wife for kids. That's
nuts. Okay. Okay. Dan himself would
never say this is true. Case in point, I
can still talk to Dan if I need to.
>> I didn't know that. I just You're
telling me?
>> I'm pretty sure there screenshots of
that as well. Yeah. So like
>> you can probably go on KA farms. You can
probably go on KA farms and find that if
you want, but I don't know.
>> No, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no.
Is there any reason to believe that I
had anything to do with that? That my
Discord had anything to do with that?
Because here's the other thing they
don't ever acknowledge is that Destiny
decided to have a personal match with
the number one Alog, the number one
doxer on Kiwi Farms that he totally got
rid of him, by the way. totally
emasculated by this guy repeatedly. But
Destiny made that a rivalry by himself
by referencing that guy by bringing up
his posts, bringing up his theories,
saying he was a loser, saying he was a
skitso, constantly constantly
interacting with his Alogs in a way that
would upset them and make them more
deranged. Right? I had nothing to do
with that. I didn't make him do that. I
would have told him not to do that. He's
the one who did it. And then he blames
me for when that guy docks people around
him. It's insane. Say his name. Why not?
Well, I could say it's Blav. Yeah, we
all know it's Blav, right? Everybody
knows it's Blav. Blav gets referenced in
Destiny. Destiny's brought Blav up
multiple times on his stream.
But I'm saying Destiny has like
literally turned it into an ego match
with this guy. And he got blown the out
by this guy, by the way, because he kept
saying, "Oh, you're wrong. You're you're
you're skitso. You could never find this
person. They're 18." And then he lost,
right? That guy did dox that person
eventually with Destiny's help and
proved she was 17. Like sad, really sad
reality that he turned it into that. But
that person hated Destiny. That that
match started before I was somebody who
was against Destiny. The reason I didn't
go on anything else is because I was
concerned that that guy was going nuts
and doxing everybody.
That was when I was friends with these
people. They offered me to come on on
anything else to get flown down to
Miami. Okay. And go on their podcast.
And I said, "No, thank you. That that
black guy is going insane. I'm not,
dude. I'm not putting my head up right
now. It's GTA five stars out here. That
Okay, I'm not stick my head up. I'm
going to keep to myself. No thank you.
No thank you. No thank you." I think
Well, he said he wanted to prove that
they couldn't dox her or something,
right? Yeah. Who knows? Lab saved you
from Epstein's Island. Well, Epstein
Island, maybe. Dude, it's like
But none of this matters. None of these
people engage with honesty, with
reality. They don't engage with
anything. They're just losers. Oh my
god.
>> Why you're trying now to Are you trying
to spread the dog's further by asking me
this?
>> That's like a loner box guy, by the way.
Spider doesn't even like me. Spider Lily
doesn't like me at all.
>> No. Who the [__] am I in the J discord,
bro?
>> How do we get out of here? He say he say
he's not to Are you trying to spread the
dog's further by asking me this?
>> No. Who the [__] am I in the J discord,
bro?
>> How do we get out of here?
>> Spider
is in the Discord all the time. Spider's
literally a member of the Discord.
>> I know. I don't know what you think. I'm
assume like roller j, bro. Like
>> nah, spider's a big big timer. Big
timer.
>> Okay.
>> I like added I I literally put a big
message like tagging somebody who used
to be in the Discord and left because
Destiny was doxing everybody everybody.
I went DJ be aware this is a JSTAR on
the run. Be aware Jstalker on the run.
Don't let him get and then I had to
delete it cuz I thought it was a little
too on the uh a little too on the nose.
I was like, "Oh, if they dox him, I'm
going to feel like horrified."
>> Yeah, I'm just saying that uh same same
logic that uh justifies Hassan getting
door logic should you should apply to
Jto community. They have the same model.
>> Uh so he says this with no proof of
anything he's saying, right? They just
repeat the same lie over and over again.
I didn't say enough on Wick. I should
have said that they are too scared. They
can't prove anything about this. They
literally have no evidence that they
could hold me to in any way. The thing
they brought up with Riyle, Riyle got
banned for that, by the way. Riyle got
banned for that even though
he was like drunk and I was like,
"Okay." Like, and then he apologized and
and it got worked out. I think I think
lots of the mods didn't like him after
that, but like it got worked out.
And again, by the way, never been the
argument that it's like just, you know,
that two random lovers can't say each
other's names in the gen chat. Okay,
that did happen. But nobody's ever
complained about that. The complaint is
harassing and doxing people around
Destiny, which has never happened.
>> Yeah. Yeah, I mean like if I see if I
hear if I have like if there's like
proof of the J community like
celebrating docs like celebrating like
um D's wife getting docks then I don't
really have like any sympathy towards
the committee or uh
like
>> Okay.
>> Yeah.
>> You know what I think the problem is
>> wait real quick walk. We're going to do
the raptors up. Okay. I think somebody
went in cuz I see them.
>> This guy's gonna This guy's about to
show that his brain is about as
attractive as his face. Give it a
second.
>> I'm not googling any though. I think the
problem is is that Discord allows any
random to create a server without any
barrier to entry.
>> We're not doing rockets. Run, run, run.
>> Don't get rocked.
>> Uh my Discord has 4,500 people in it.
Whatever the barrier is, I passed that
barrier a long time ago. Again, actual
subhuman ADIQ
loser. Uh that could be a problem.
That's not anything that helps here.
That was the dumbest thing I've ever
heard said in my entire life. Oh, is
there wizard block? Keep running. Keep
running.
Are you in?
>> I'm in. Are you saying zero?
>> We'll see if uh we'll see if spider's
going to say anything. He got the [__]
out. I'm wait here for a sec. There
might be somebody running over there.
[__]
Okay,
>> open up.
>> I posted something in P's Discord and
deleted it.
Are you talking about this?
>> Talking about the current the current
stream or what? No, no, just talking
about
>> No, we don't support Joang T.
>> Bro, I don't want to get [__]
>> I'm shooting.
>> I don't give a [__] Okay, I'm in
[__] the Jag Discord. I don't give a
[__] Okay, I left. I'm not in there
anymore. Okay, go [__]
>> No, I was in there, but I left now. I
left out. I left now. Um,
>> do bad,
>> dude. I don't know. Yeah, the the the
amp the dancing back and forth between
No, we have to go after these people cuz
they dox and doxing is what you should
be allowed to do anyways. Is doxing even
that bad, guys?
>> Uhhuh.
>> If you do someone, you should I don't
care if you get doxed. Like that's not
that.
>> Mhm.
>> Are they listening?
Go hop on. Huh? Unless you're
>> Well, I wasn't listening this morning.
>> I I'm not going to talk to this destiny
loser. I'm not not with uh I just I'm
never ever gonna give him like a hint of
anything going on with his stuff, right?
With any of his legal and I am totally
fine answering like what do you call it
like u asynchronous questions but I'm
not going to I'm not going to be in a
call with him to have him spur out and
act like a child the whole time like he
did with Doobie. It's gross. No, but
also it's just that so even if I didn't
have information that like I'm not
giving him a hint on like I'm never
going to actually just answer a question
from him like on the fly. Even if that
weren't the case, even if I wasn't
concerned about that, I've seen from the
Pisco conversation and the Doobie
conversation, there's no way to have a
conversation with this guy unless
someone's willing to mute him where he's
not just going to spur and try to like
shift the entire time you're talking,
right?
did well in the debate last night. Oh,
my wand. My one did well. Yeah. Yeah.
Oh, I didn't even see that yet. I didn't
see get a chance to see any of that. But
no, we'll see. We'll see. We'll see.
He'll just leave. He isn't used to being
muted. Uh maybe
I just like there's just no reason to
have the conversation. Like I am totally
fine with if he wants to lay out
questions he has for me. I'm fine with
taking my time answering them and then
asking a question back,
right?
But that's not what he wants. That's why
he's got me blocked on Twitter.
>> Wait, Dirt Zero. Is your name dirty the
zero?
>> So, what happened to you during the
forth thing? Uh, no. That's actually not
true. Creeper dude. When you listen to
the f to that conversation, I'm saying
the things that are correct. I didn't
realize until after that that talk that
I said all the things that correct. I
was correct in that conversation. I like
went and watched it after the fact.
But it doesn't matter, right? cuz he's
like like literally in this entire
space. If you're in this space, you've
been like programmed to listen to this
guy and think like spurking out at 90
miles a minute saying nothing relevant
to any point is good is like a win. It's
like a W.
Uh I got this from I actually got this
from Nick Fuentes. I went to go watch
when I was a big DG head. I went to go
watch and debunk one of Nick's streams
like trying to on Destiny and I noticed
that when he slowed it down and it's
like it's not totally fair because it's
hard to speak fast like on the fly and
like get your ideas out on the fly. But
when you slow him down and just listen
when he's doing that like motormouth
thing where he's listing all these
things, he's not thinking. He's just in
list mode trying to say anything he can.
And when you put it all together, it's
just like a co of it's a it's an
argument co. Okay. bunch of really
arguments put together, rattled off
really quickly to make it sound like
he's informed or correct. But if you
slow it down and say, "I want to talk
about this." He tries to he tries to run
past it, right? CDO collateralized debt
obligation. Collateralized debate
obligation. Okay, that's what he does.
Isn't that a gish gallop? Um, well, it's
a it's probably a gish gallop. Yeah.
Yeah, it's probably a gish galp, I would
say.
Um, but yeah, collateralized debate
obligation. It's just a bunch of
arguments. I guess it is a Gishkal, but
it's the way he does it like speedily
and then he basically keeps trying to
move you forward in the conversation,
right? And he'll say, "No, you're not
answering me. No, you're not answering
me." But he just said like four or five
things,
probably three of them. Totally. And he
never wants to stop and let you answer
them. Yeah. No, it is like a co Wendy.
Yeah, exactly. Gish Gallop is multiple
arguments, not just listing things.
Well, it's sort of like multiple reasons
why he believes something, right? And
he'll go LIKE, "OH MY GOD, ARE you
kidding me? There's nothing but there's
this and this this this this this." And
that you when he's doing it, verbal
cover fire is a good one. Yeah, I like
it. But it's um it's just obvious. And
there's very little you can do about
that on the fly, right? All you can do
is stand is stand still and say, "I'm
not moving until we discuss the thing
you just said." But then it's just going
to turn into a meta argument, right? And
he would much rather have that meta
argument than the actual conversation.
Is what you're referring to? I clipped
it when you referenced it yesterday. Oh,
did you?
Hold on. Yeah. I I just find it funny
that I was like I was watching some
Fentto's piece of content because he
covered Destiny. I was like, "Oh, I
should like debunk this on stream and
show like how easy it is to do this."
Like
>> he mentioned closing waterways has been
a historical norm for war and now now
international law doesn't matter.
>> It's No, no. I'm just saying that like
when I'm looking at like justifications
for either side, what I'm thinking of is
like a like a war crime or not is not
like I'm just trying to look at the
reality of the situation on the ground.
Like for instance, it might
>> What?
This is what I'm talking about, but I
thought it was a different thing. This
is going to be a different thing. This
is Destiny like speaking fast and then
saying things that like he uses so many
words because he doesn't want the other
person to talk, right? So, he's using so
many words,
but he's not thinking about the words.
>> Dude, what? Let's Let's play that back
in 75 and write it down and let's see
how stupid that sounds when you don't
say it with any confidence, you know,
cuz Hey,
>> he's out. He's attacking the tone
indicators.
He He was calling out the tone
indicators in 2022, 2023. What the is
like, "Wait a second. You don't care
about what's a war crime, but you just
said that that Israel is justified
because Egypt committed a war crime.
What's your response?"
No,
I'm just saying that like when I'm
looking at like justifications for
either side, what I'm thinking of is
like a like a war crime or not is like
I'm just trying to look at the reality
of the situation on the ground.
So, no, I'm not looking at definitions.
I'm just looking at the situation on the
ground is all of that,
>> right?
>> The response to what he's like the fact
that he's responding to a question like
that is it makes it significantly worse.
You mentioned
>> how easily Desi can confuse people in
the right is impressive.
Is it? Is it? It's Yeah, maybe.
It certainly works.
It's like, man, I just can't get over
how Trumpian it's become. It's all
become.
>> Closing waterways has been a historical
norm for war and now now internet.
>> Yeah. Anyway, that is the clip that's
shocking that you got the precise clip I
was thinking of right here where you
slow it down and then you laugh at these
people or you laugh at him specifically.
It's way worse with the listing. And
Pisco is trying to do that, right? Pisco
is listening to him listing off reasons
that like Pisco is wrong or Pisco is
stupid or Pisco is like bad faith. And
Pisco will go, "Whoa, you just said
this. Can we go back and like analyze
this?" And he go, "No, no, no. You're
not even listening to what I'm saying.
I'm trying to say like something, no,
no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no. We can't
go back. I'm going to go No, no, no, NO,
NO, NO, NO, NO. You have to listen to me
right now. I'm going to talk right now
and I'm going to go really fast on it.
$1, $2, $3 350. So for $350, like that's
the whole game, right? And by the time
he's gone through like four things like
that, Pisco doesn't even remember the
character attack that was like 90
seconds ago, but a thousand words ago.
So that's the issue. That's why I'm just
like, "Okay, I will respond to him,
right? just either write down what you
want to ask or I'm totally fine like
writing back and forth what it is, but
the problem is if you write it back and
forth, you lose the tone indicators,
right?
You have to present your evidence and
make the argument. You lose the tone
indicators, which is like 90% of the
battle for him, and you let the other
person respond categorically. If he had
to have text conversations over this, he
would get decimated. Don't you dare ask
him to speak slower? Well, the funny
thing is Ozel is he used to allow people
to go like, "Hey, slow down. Slow down.
Let's like talk through this, but he
didn't do it Pisco." And if he's not
going to do it for a guy who was like
one of his best friends just like a year
ago, there's no shot he's going to do it
for me. 0% chance.
>> Doesn't matter.
>> It's No. No. I'm just saying that.
>> Oh, I don't want to keep doing this.
>> Are we almost done with Spider? Jesus
Christ. Spider, finish.
dirty zero.
>> Uh,
>> I
Okay, this is the last day we're going
to spend more than like an hour on this
stuff. Okay, I don't care if we want to
do like updates in days, but this is
like got to be like the last day we
spend more than an hour on this stuff
cuz it's like actually crazy how much
time it takes.
>> Do you say like do you have that same
like um what's the word?
So, I mean with like no new
developments, it was just people talking
about it randomly or whatever. It's not
a big deal.
>> What about food shops like saying like,
"Oh, I don't care if like Dan someone's
family gets [__] ducks or sorted."
Like, do you care?
>> She said she didn't care. Not that it
happened.
>> Uh, she said it was good. She said she
hopes it happens. That's actually
different. I I'm almost positive she
said she hopes it happens, right? I'm
glad I'm glad that your wife gets
harassed. Uh,
>> I think she was
>> Spider just asked
raging out. I don't know if her
community does that. So, when she says
it, I don't know how likely it is that
someone will do it.
>> Her community does do that. It's
literally the Destiny community.
>> I I know that uh the people inside of J
>> Spider's on a quest of discovery. I have
faith he'll get there eventually. Spider
on his quest of discovery is going to
discover Atlantis. He's going to find a
way that no sane person could ever find
and he's going to find Atlantis. Okay,
that's what he's going to discover.
Nobody, nobody with any, you know, any
functioning five senses could possibly
find it, but he'll find the path
somehow.
>> Community when they say we should do
someone or we should harass someone,
they actually do it or it happens right
after someone says that. So I think the
cause of link is much higher when those
people say something like that. But if
if if that happens after hop say it, I
think uh she should face some
consequence for that as well. Yeah.
Shooting.
Oh, I'm not even listen. I don't care
about this. I don't care. I'd rather
listen to Pisco do his little thing at
the beginning or whatever. His like
little blurb. We'll watch the Pisco blur
and then we'll
>> I don't know how much longer I'm going
to stream for and I will
>> I know it's kind of
>> see if people come on. I get that. This
is the other thing is if I do this
content, if I do like the Destiny
adjacent content, I'm not going to get
I'm not going to be able to get people
to come on, right? That's the other
thing. And I like doing collaborative
content. I like having people come on.
So for as long as I talk about Destiny
to any like significant degree, I won't
be able to get people on because he's
just going to threaten to dox them. So
even if it's like even if it's like just
sort of adjacent in time, I think. So I
probably have to chill on the coverage
there or it's going to start to really
affect the stream.
>> Five to 10. We'll do encounters with uh
bigger streamers with
with like breaking points with other
people I can collab with for the goal of
like getting my name out there. But I'm
not trying to pander or cater or attack
particular communities except perhaps
with the exception of MAGA, the the
community of people who are running our
country right now. Maybe with that
particular exception. Um you might not
believe me. That's my intent. And why
would I, right? Why would I want to
needlessly antagonize people? I don't
have any interest in being like
disliked. Who has that desire? I don't
want to be disliked.
I generally want to be liked. Um but I
also don't want to be like this fake
person who just tries to be nice with
everyone. I kind of take the view that
um if you haven't like made enemies or
like made people upset, you're probably
doing something wrong.
Is Perry at risk? Perry's lucky because
he's uh banned from the Discord.
>> That doesn't mean you want people to be
>> Oh, I haven't watched the action of Vell
video yet either. Damn.
>> Or angry at you or consider you to be
like, I don't know, Persona Nrada. Uh
that I certainly don't want that. But as
a consequence of like ever making any
kind of opinion known. Um I guess if all
you did was like cooking streams, you
could write that line. Harry's banned
for um streaming from the Discord in a
non-sreamable Discord. It's going to be
banned for a while. Can't let that go
down, man.
>> But then it's you probably get someone
who like doesn't agree with what you
call a sandwich or you know, you're not
supposed to use cream and uh carbonara
or some other debate or some [__] you
know? So, by virtue of being on the
internet and having a society, you're
going to upset some people. But it's not
my like desire to do that. I don't want
again hate. I don't want to cause hate.
You know the kind of people I interact
with all the time that we disagree
massively. Rob no, good logic.
>> He's talking about that. [__] I have to
go back to the beginning. I might have
to go find a time stamp for this. Um but
the Perry stuff it's just a Yeah. Fact
of the matter. If you if you're
streaming and you're going to
Yeah. like pull that up. Wait, he
doesn't have like cams up or something.
He like literally Yeah. I don't know. I
he might not ever be coming back to the
discord.
>> Viva Frey um counter points.
>> And that sucks cuz I like Perry, but
like literally nothing of value is lost
for as long as he's going to be a
performative like
refuse to engage like seriously with
anyone
and just violate the rules in general.
Like it's just like, okay, you've made
yourself like totally radioactive. And
it's sad because I I find you funny, but
like if you're gonna make yourself
totally radioactive, don't make me stand
there and get cancer.
>> Uh Hutch, it is not my desire. I don't
get any gratification from seeing these
people suffer
or wanting my people to go attack their
communities or anything. There are
comments that um in like my chats and
stuff or in my discord that are highly
critical of other people and streamers.
I my policy has been usually one of
maximal free speech.
>> By the way, um just in case people think
this, Alex Novel didn't complain to me
or anything. I don't think he messaged
me about it. Did he talk to me about it?
I didn't talk to him about it. I just
found out that Perry made a video and I
literally just went to go look at who
was in my VC and what VC they were in.
It wasn't from the streamable VC. I just
instantly banned Perry. I didn't even
know what was really going on. I just
heard Perry made a video from the
Discord and then I saw what video or
what channel he's making it from
immediately like no thank you.
>> You know, I'm I'm going to be real with
you. I never argued on these kind of
like Twitch platforming or um you
banning censorship stuff that it was
right to ban all these Trump people or
all these antivax or whatever.
Okay. I always just said like it's not a
government issue. It's not Biden's
fault. it.
>> So, this is nothing to do with this
actually like a this is a really
horrible example for what's going on
right now. I don't know why he's talking
about ideas.
It's not ideas. It's that you have
somebody who is like actively it's like
saying, well, like I think people should
have freedom of speech. So, when this
guy says that he shouldn't have to wear
a mask and he should be allowed to cough
on whoever he wants, I just let him into
my store cuz I believe in freedom of
speech. Well, it's like, no, they're
actually advocating for like doxing
people um based on no criteria, nothing
they can prove, right? Just vibes.
That's it. And they just tied you to the
vibes. You shouldn't really have to
think about who's in the right or wrong
here. It's very obvious who's in the
wrong. I've never threatened Pisco in
any way. I've actually I've never got
I've made it very clear. Do not go after
in like a in any way except laughing at
them any of the people I cover on
stream. This is all meant to just be
we're laughing. As up as it is, you
don't go after them for anything else,
okay? Unless they've done something
specifically to you. Even from Pisco's
own interest, Destiny was endorsing
Well, sorry. Yeah. No, it's in Pisco's
interest not to have people who will
argue for doxing with no proof, right?
That's bad. That's obviously bad. Um,
all of those people were trying to
stream from his Discord, trying to break
his rules. What happened when people
brought up the Destiny drama with Zip
Zip there? I disconnected instantly. I
went to my Discord. I ated. I said,
"Don't talk about that in their Discord.
Pisco doesn't want that in his discord."
I joined one of my own VCs to bring
people over to my discord. Right? That's
what somebody said the word destiny. I
was like, "Okay, I'm out. Bye."
Disconnected, went to my discord, joined
a different channel, adhered, got
everybody. I said, "Hey, if you want to
join a VC, I'm in a VC now. Do not talk
about that in Pisco's Discord. That's
not what he wants." What did Destiny's
community do? What did Destiny and
Destiny's community do? Destiny went to
Pisco's Discord to litigate this
specifically the thing he did that Pisco
didn't want litigated. I didn't I talked
about Zip Zip's combo with Pisco. That's
what I talked about. And then I went to
I went to listen to the Pis the Pisco
Zip Zip combo because I'd heard that
Pisco is not being gentle with him.
Okay. Pisco is kind of like tearing this
guy limb from limb. It was very funny.
And then I was playing Civ and then I
asked Zip Zip some questions and then I
dipped the out. That's That's how that
went. I didn't go to discuss drama at
all. The only time I've discussed drama
in Pisco's Discord is when I feel like I
should defend myself in some way. Like
I'm being I'm being accused of something
I didn't do. Other people bring it up. I
think I should have the right to
respond.
And I didn't even I even didn't do that
occasionally. I would say I would
message him out and be like, "Hey, this
person is bringing this up. Can I
respond, please?"
That level Okay. That level of of
colored person existence. Okay, that's
what I that's what I am in Pisco's
Discord. Okay, I'm I go to the colors
only fountain in Pisco's Discord. Okay,
that's how it is. And I'm okay with
that. I'll deal with that and show
people that like I'm not going crazy.
I'm not like I'm not trying to get
anybody hurt, obviously.
And that whenever somebody says that
I've done something that I haven't done,
I'll just go, "Hey, do can you prove
that at all? Can you literally show me
any evidence of what you're saying?" No,
actually mass hysteria never happens.
Mass delusion never happens. Certainly,
we're not in a cult. Pisco is, as Pisco
is watching people tell him that they
can't believe how bad faith he was to
Hutch when Hutch gas lit him for like an
hour and a half, wouldn't answer a
single hypothetical, made a face, like
Pisco is the every single time Pisco
asked him a question for like an hour
and a half before Pisco became any
amount of heated at all. And then he
gets told, "Hey, why are you like so
bad? Why are you like such an to Hutch?
Why are you such an evil person to
Hutch?"
Holy.
So he sees it. Everybody sees it who's
not
but man I'm
as one step two steps forward one step
back is like how it feels. Okay. Like I
see Pisco seeing it and then I see other
people I'm like dude these people suck.
Anyway anyway
>> it's not like coercion but they and
they're private companies. They can do
what they want. That was always extend
my argument.
>> This might be controversial for some of
you.
I would let antivaxers on Twitch. Okay.
Maybe I would think hard about it in the
context of
>> so in a pandemic
>> antiaxers talking to them about being
antiax is something right talking to
them about it but then letting them
congregate around you in your physical
space or if somebody's a doctor letting
them congregate around you in your
digital space. That is scary right and
then it comes down to analyzing. I say I
don't want doxing in my community. I
don't allow anybody who doxes. I don't
allow post of like screenshots from
Kiwi. None of that stuff's allowed in my
community. It's not allowed. Hasn't been
allowed since before Destiny made these
allegations, right?
And people just lie about my position.
It's literally me saying, "I don't
support doxing. I don't like doxing.
Doxing is gross.
It's obviously like the exact position
everybody else has had forever." Right?
And then they say, "No, you do. You do
you you like that position? I'm like,
"No, I don't. Show me any events." And
they're like, "Everyone knows,
brother." What? Sorry, I'm talking play.
I'm play agencies that will change my
mind about
>> The idea is is that there's a reason you
have certain policies in place. And when
you have doxers, them being there
supporting doxing saying, "Hey, I should
dox anybody who does like XYZ." And
after you've been green lit by Destiny,
right, which he'll totally roll back
because he he knows he can't actually
stand on that. But when you've been
green lit by Destiny, every anybody in
your Discord is green lit, too. And then
he's constantly saying, "Oh, why won't
anybody help me dox? I need to dox so
many more people. Why won't anybody help
me?" Like, that is a that's a risk,
right? That is a threat. Certain types
of stuff. But in general, I'm pro free
speech. I don't love all the algorithm
changes and all the stupid [__] that
Avon has done on Twitter, but in
general, I am happy that a bunch of
people got unbanned. That's my
substantive position. And I carry that
value through into how I run a lot of my
chats to the chagrin of even some of my
mods. I see for example Tomato in the
chat who is often frustrated with me
because um she like I don't give her
good guidelines as to who to ban and who
to like time out and stuff. And the
reason is I have just a very relaxed
I've always had a very relaxed policy
and everyone knows that. Um and even bad
faith criticism of myself I let stay on
my comments. I there people sometimes
like listen who will be there and will
be like wait why are you like muting
comments or like that doesn't happen. Um
maybe there's like a YouTube thing
sometimes if you like do certain work
>> isn't doobie banned. Yeah he I think he
joked about zip zip coming on car doors
>> but it's never a process of mine. You
have to reach some like very high
threshold for me personally to like want
to want to even mute you.
>> I haven't muted many people on Twitter.
Sometimes I like I don't see everything
where I'm being pinged on Twitter just
because of I I I get a lot of pings and
stuff. So I miss stuff, but I'm not the
kind of person who tends to block, who
tends to ban. Um, and anyone who's kind
of interacted with me knows that it's
like cuz I liked the disagreements that
it's no other reason other than like
it's a kind of thing I like and I like
disagreeing with people and for it to be
sort of limited to the disagreement.
That's always been how I've operated.
Okay, that said, there always have to be
rules, right? No one under 18 allowed in
the server. What are the other rules?
against rules.
No encouraging things that are like toos
um to the for for some of these places.
Um hate speech, even though I don't like
agree with hate speech as like a as like
a legal like you should be banned for
saying hate speech or you should be in
trouble for it. Um I do think that
that's usually in line with to same
thing with like NS NSFW. There are some
areas where I'm like, okay, it's not
that kind of place. Okay. And even
though I think like there's a high
standard for like the criminal world of
threats, encouragement, that kind of
stuff, it's different when it comes to
like this is all stuff you probably
know, right? It's like a lower
threshold. Like even if this wouldn't
meet the criminal standard, if you're
kind of encouraging bad stuff from like
a direct way, oh, my bad. That's going
to be banned. So there are some
limitations. I'm not trying to say
there's speeding up.
>> Um but in general, like very very
um liberal in the sense of allowing
disscent, allowing a difference of
opinion and what have you. By and large,
it's focused on politics, law stuff.
>> Absolute free speech is a gateway to
hell. Literally, nobody's advocating for
absolute.
>> Okay, that's um some baseline. And like
I mentioned before, I don't have an
intent like I don't want to upset people
on purpose. When I have debates, even
very vigorous debates, even [__] with
like um Tim Pool, like Tim offline, we
he accused Tim accused me of supporting
the shooting of these National Guard
people publicly in front of everybody.
And even after that, right, like I don't
want to I I'm not in the mood like it
doesn't make me necessarily happy to see
um bad things happen to him or anything
like that, except if he like broke a law
or something or if he like, you know,
some [__]
>> So the long and short of this, by the
way, is that Pisco is banning all
discussion of Ethan and Destiny from his
>> related to misconduct, you know, but
just on the basis of that, that's not
it, right? Doesn't mean I don't I'm not
petty. I don't sometimes have like ego
arguments to defend my positions when I
think they're being unfairly attacked,
but in general, that's my stance. Um,
and all types are allowed. Everyone gets
a chance
to be in compliance with the rules. Um,
especially on the server. Yes, in the
chats and that kind of thing. You get a
chance.
Okay. Um, so let's talk a little bit
about the more specifics. I'm aware that
there are snarker communities, right?
There are communities who are dedicated
to um snarking which is like runs the
gamut from like unfair
slash weird creepy logging of people's
activities. Um I'm going to turn off the
sound but thank you very much. Tracking
people what they say criticizing them.
Right. So things that are um
>> wait should that really be two and
three? Hold on. One I can kind of get
being creepy. Wait, why did he say the
second two?
>> Thank you very much.
>> Tracking people what they say,
criticizing them, right? So things that
are
>> cracking what people say and then
criticizing them.
>> What that is weird or offputting or
annoying or criticism, right? They run
the game from that to like criminal
activity, um things that are harassment
that infringe on people's privacy. And I
think that it should be clear that I
never want that. I do not want to
encourage that kind of stuff and I
wholeheartedly condemn the that side of
it. I think that there's a difference
between like genuine criticism uh people
talking about hypocrisies to the kind of
activities that um put people in fear or
that where it's reasonably questionable
whether privacy interests are being
respected um or whether people are sort
of encouraging other things that kind of
thing but it's not my intention to
promote um that version of sarking
>> and even beyond that um the kind of
single-minded focus on a on particular
individuals is something I don't want to
encourage either. I don't want to be a
place whose only identifying feature or
um through line pertains to one or two
or three individuals except for me. I
want the through line of my community to
be about me. I don't want it to be about
other
>> I wish I had the choiceing specific
creators.
>> I sure love watching the right-wing
covering all that. I wish I had a
choice.
>> That includes
>> everyone else is like I'm just staying
in my lane. I'm just staying in my lane.
Meanwhile, Destiny's like cutting uh
he's like actually just sending
consistent uh what is it? Jams into my
community and they're like, "Well, I
wouldn't want to look over there. That
sure sucks, man. I wish that wasn't
happening. Here, Desty, here's a bunch
of money for more JDAMs."
There's some analogy here where the the
communities are the US. Okay. It's like,
bro, I just You guys call this guy out?
What the going on? It's like you're
under a spell.
that includes um Destiny that includes
>> specifically
>> that includes any number of different
creators and stuff. I don't want my
community to be just places where the
focus is only on particular individuals.
The kind of thing that happens after
that is it becomes a more like snark
congregating situation. So I don't want
my stuff to be that.
>> You know I have issues with people like
Adam friended and what he's uh you know
he blocked me and
>> I do I do get what he's saying. I wish I
had a choice man.
>> I've had issues with um other streamers
etc. You you you don't see in my videos
that I I post out there just like one
person going after them all the time,
right? Except for Trump and MAGA and
like politics stuff, right? But
certainly not of the streamer kind
because it's not my interest and it's
not what I want to cultivate. That's
about intent. Now, I think the kind of
standard that I impose on my community
is one that ought by and large perhaps
with some exceptions. You guys can talk
about that if you want in this chat.
Don't [__] talk about in the discord.
That's we'll talk about the rule change
um momentarily, but just know that
everything's in here. The rule is clear
in the discord. All right, that the
standards that I apply for my community
are self-standing and self-contained.
You know, think about the issue with the
Venezuelan interceptions, right, of the
Americans going to intercept in
international waters. I don't think that
my rules apply outside of where I hold a
dominion, which is my different places.
Okay, there's a kind of limitation both
that I think I can do, right? But also
one in which I think is like reasonable
to expect in that the server isn't a
kind of social club where we're checking
applications at the door to make sure
that you're you're have a good
character. It's not like in a some kind
of co-op where we're getting statements
of good character, you know, your
invoices and stuff. It's a generally
open space of people to participate and
the rules of
bro. Okay, don't give me friends. J's
community is pretty intense in terms of
their intentions, but I don't see doxing
or harassment or celebration of doing so
in there.
Um,
okay, dude. Um,
I was just, dude, Pisco people be like,
Pisco is so bad. Faith with Hutch. It's
crazy. He's so wordy all the time. You
ever listen to this guy yap by himself?
This guy can't make a point to save his
life by himself. Okay.
And you're going to say he's bad faith
to Hutch. No, he's bad faith to
humanity. He's always this wordy. Okay.
He's by himself just yapping to his
chat. And he's still this wordy of the
space. Don't go elsewhere. Except to
which there's like a hook to conduct on
>> I shouldn't yell if you're someplace
else and and the conduct affects the
server in that you're um invoking it or
you're directing stuff to it. That
that's areas in which um obviously
there's like a hook to the the server
conduct. Um, I also think it's a bit
much to expect that other rules, rule
sets from other places predominate my
space, right? Because everyone has their
own rules.
Everyone has their own standards for
what is acceptable and what is not
acceptable.
>> I get how this is like good when you're
the
It's probably because I think I listened
to this this morning. I I just couldn't
sleep today. Okay. So, I was like
listening on and off to stuff like as I
was falling in and out of sleep and I
think I listened to most of this. So, I
already get the point. He's basically
gonna say like, I can't control other
people's [__] but this is how it's
going to be here. I want my community to
be about me, about my ideas. And he was
like, I don't want to make money. Like,
I could just do snarking if I want to
make money. No, that's not like how you
make money. You make money by carving
out a lane for yourself. You got to
carve out a lane, bro. And I think he
the best lane he can carve out is like
the legal one who gives his legal
opinion on things. But I do think there
could be a pretty big lane for the guy
who like goes in on Ethan Klein and
shows just like is willing to argue
those things, which you probably can't
argue that with DJers, right? And I
think he he was going around arguing his
friends, arguing with his friends. If he
could have pulled like a Dioro debate,
if he could have pulled like a Ethan
Klein direct debate, if he could have
pulled a debate with one of these
people, that would be different.
>> You know, want to create a snark
community of a certain kind. Maybe it's
the kind which is really bad. Maybe it's
the kind which is just like kind of mere
criticism. Maybe it's like you don't
remember fundy snark which is like the
fundamentalist snark. Maybe it's like a
topic related snark. Maybe it's banan
pit poles whatever that's their
responsibility that's them. They do they
go do that and their participation in
that I think um you know is their
interest but it's not something that I
until and unless it is directly
implicated how I want to run the server
relating to me. In other words, everyone
gets a shot in the place to follow my
rules in my place.
And if someone tries to tell me, hey,
you should run your server differently.
These are the kinds of things that you
should do. I'm interested in hearing
that. Tell me why. Uh, not through
Discord. Okay? I mean, like
conceptually, I mean, so don't go tell
me send all seven stuff in Discord.
Okay? So again, reiterating the rule in
Discord is as it is. It hasn't changed.
But what I mean to say is like I'm open
to hearing.
>> Imagine if he could have got in a legal
mindset conversation on that. That's
where I think he'd have to go, right? is
to he'd have to start breaking into I
don't know why he doesn't just go argue
with these law people all the time on
everything. Go figure out what legal
mindset's doing videos on criticize. Go
figure out dude
L tube Stark would go pretty insane.
Okay, I think L tube Stark could be I
mean L tube basically is Stark already,
but it could go crazy. I'm telling you
>> on other circumstances like what are
better ways in which one should ought to
run their server or their different
place or their chat, whatever, right?
I'm open to that. 100%.
>> He has done that. I
I know kind of
>> what I don't accept.
>> Wait, and Bailey isn't like the uh Hold
on. Who's and Bailey? I don't know who
these
>> I'm not just
>> I just I'm going to click on it cuz I
just want to see real quick. Wr of the
Bailey YouTube. Wr of the Bailey. No,
no, no, no, no. Oh, that guy. Oh, that
guy. I recognize that guy's face. I
recognize that dude. That dude's got a
really memorable face. I'm not defending
J, whatever. Oh, by the way, um, one
thing clear,
>> hold on, hold on, hold on. Let me go
back.
>> I I I truly, you know, I probably the
best amongst us if I if I have to say
anything. And, uh, all the hate he
receives online entirely, bro. The [__]
is this? Just the the Ultra Orthodox Jew
by Israel's draft. What your ball size
says about you. Final Fantasy 10 by
Gracini Project. Venu me. Venu meles.
It's my life. whatever I want to do.
>> What an eclectic set of tastes we got
over here, guys.
>> Uh, but I'm I'm not willing to defend
him against the charges of being the new
Duke Docker.
>> Yeah, dude. Can you have a like a
personality trait? Sorry.
>> All right. I'm not I'm not defending J.
Whatever. Oh, by the way, um, one thing
clear, I have not made any assertion as
to the rightness or wrongness of any
particular um I was looking at VOD and I
saw something coming up from from where
he's like, I didn't do certain things.
I'm not making any characterizations of
anyone's conduct as relates to what I
don't want to talk about. So, I hope
that that is clear that when I'm
speaking hypothetically and
conditionally that um those aren't
assertions of fact.
>> It was it was absolutely not clear. So
much so that like people were really mad
at me for not calling you out. And so I
did actually say like I'm pretty sure
this is what he means, but if he didn't,
I think I would like a like an
acknowledgement of that.
People were really mad at me for not
calling him out for just like sort of
taking as given some of those things.
But
>> we love you here at the bunker. I think
people everyone that calls you a tail
pipe is just out of line. Um and and
we'll ban them from the bunker. So, we
love you, but we're not going to talk
about boring legal topics tonight. We're
only talking about the most interesting
legal topics.
>> Wait,
they'll ban somebody who calls Wait, is
that Zip Zip? Was Zip Zip on this? They
They banned somebody who calls Zip Zip a
tailpipe from their Discord. That's just
funny, bro. That's just funny, dog. Oh,
man. I do wonder I do wonder if there
could be like a little clip is does
somebody have a clip of like the morale?
We do have a clip.
Oh, I gotta watch I gotta That's an
offshoot server. Yeah, I gotta watch
He's watching his the podcast of his
like offshoot guys. Um I gotta watch the
clip of Mau talking to Zip Zip to see
it. I'm not going to play it because I
just said I wouldn't obviously a little
while ago, but um like I just I
I'm just positive I know exactly how
Morau delivered it.
>> And starting off with you think is the
worst lawyer streamer? There's
>> Nope. What a great intro. See,
>> what part of I said I'm not going to
play it, so I'm not going to play it.
What What part of that was confusing?
>> This is This is a guy with a planet.
Now, Gond, as I understand, he he like
floats in and out of different lawyer
communities. I think he's an OG Bosiot
guy. I think that that's right.
>> They're both OG Bosiot guys. I'm pretty
sure they're both like massive Bosia
fans
>> and will not accept
>> whatever
>> from being convinced that I ought to run
my server a different way is suggesting
that
>> um I have to run my server
the way that other people say I ought to
run it. That is where I'm like why and
for the longest time.
Why'd you ban me out from it to make a
point that I was going to first and ask
questions later that like I'm pretty
confident he's like um joking there but
I would have to hear it exactly and so I
just banned I just banned first and then
I'll go and look at it and we'll figure
it out. I just wanted Zip Zip to admit
that he felt threatened
and then hopefully since I since I knew
that there was somebody who did record
it and it got leaked I was like well I
can go grab it as well. I have an
awareness that people have different
views on this
like um war between communities
specific. Pisco's new rule only benefits
Destiny and um he was manipulated into
it directly by Destiny, but it's like it
doesn't make it wrong for his part,
right? Like it that can be true, but it
can still be the most beneficial path he
could take. And I pro I would probably
agree that that's what it is, right?
It's just the most beneficial path for
him to take. And but he was like like
literally I already explained Queen and
I dipped before anybody brought the
Destiny stuff, right? I heard the word
Destiny. I I peeled the out of that VC.
I was like, "Nope, I'm not doing that in
Pisco's Discord, right? What did Destiny
do? Destiny's community tried rereaming
the Discord multiple times to make it
about that." And then Destiny joined and
made it about that, right? He wanted to
litigate his drama with people. I
explicitly try to go to my Discord and
say, "Hey, if you guys want to talk
about drama, come talk about it here."
Right? So, I think like all of this
stuff is just Destiny trying to force
Pisco to stop talking about it. And he
was effective and he he like got it to
happen. Um, but I also think that like
for what Pisco wants to do, it's true
that he doesn't want to be involved in
that. He probably just doesn't want to
be around any of that, right?
It's it's just that's the case, man. So
I if it wasn't if it was like like way
worse for him somehow if he was really
struggling if his numbers were really
bad and he like probably needed to get
like an injection of content some way
like maybe I could criticize it but
realistically the guy gets like a good
amount of content even for like some
stuff that I find super boring right
like when he's just reading documents. I
don't think he has to do that and I
think he's building his niche out and I
think when you're on YouTube and you
have like access to the algorithm you
just build your niche man.
I don't know. Destiny did put his foot
in his mouth a few fair few times from
what I heard. Okay. Well, we'll see. See
if it makes a difference.
>> On the Destiny side of things and on the
anti-destiny side of things. And my
position is listen, I don't want to
cultivate either. I don't want to be in
a situation in which I'm encouraging
like pro- snark positions or antisark
position such that I am getting dragged
into this mess of stuff I don't want to
talk about and that don't interest me.
And doesn't that make all the sense in
the world that I wouldn't want that? Who
would who would want that? Why would I
want that? So, there appears to be
>> so rare Emory W. This is probably true,
but I'm never going to go and like push
Bisco on it cuz I don't think it'll
happen. Like I I think probably anybody
who advocates for doxing as a sincere
position should be banned and like
actively engages in it and actively
engages in it against like people who
are your friends, people who are your
like colleagues, people around you. I
don't think you can entertain that. I
think that's probably going to be bad
for your space overall. But
hey, or he just like my community and
then none of you guys cross him and you
all pretend like he's really cool and
awesome and then I think that works out
for everybody except for me, right? Like
eventually if he just like totally my
community by doxing anybody who's active
enough and and doesn't like him and then
you guys like all pretend it didn't
happen. I think that could work out well
for everyone else. Probably
>> um a suggestion
I should preemptively ban.
>> That's like a That's like a joke but not
a joke. You know this one of those jokes
that's a joke but it's not really a joke
but it's like kind of a joke cuz I don't
think it'll happen but also ah you never
know
>> certain people from either sides of that
divide.
>> I think I think realistically we've hit
like bedrock on the people who will be
threatened away. You know what I'm
saying? Like I think we just straight up
hit bedrock on the people who will be
threatened away
and it's probably not going to work out.
Yeah, if that was like it's like there
are people who will leave because of it,
but it's like realistically the people
Destiny actually scared away were like
the sane people who would defend like
all of the lawyers who used to come in
and defend his side of the case in the
discord all left. And there were a bunch
there were a bunch of people who come in
and defend his side of the case from
like the same perspective just being
like, "Well, I think the law is like
this and I I think this is like how this
is." And they changed my mind on a bunch
of things. They like help me understand
a whole bunch of things. But now those
people are all gone.
But maybe that's what he wants. Maybe he
wants to like try to fment the community
into something more intense than what it
is. I don't know. From the
>> Oh, that's unfortunately for him. if he
wants to make it like more intense and
get them to do some crazy, that's never
going to work, right? Like I'm always
going to be against that. And I've
already been tested on that so many
times, right? I've been tested on that
so many times.
>> Yo, you shouldn't be talking to
counterpoints. You shouldn't be allowing
Zip Zip in your server. These are just
people who are
>> Oh, hold on. Hold on. Is he acting like
he gets this comment from people? I will
say Zip Zip does a lot of defending
doxing with zero thought behind it.
makes it pretty weird. But
>> from either side of that divide, from
the pro Destiny side, you know, you
shouldn't be talking to counterpoints.
You shouldn't be allowing Zip Zip in
your server. These are just people who
are um actively trying to defend some
>> horrible stuff that's happening and that
stuff. So, understand,
>> but like does he get that criticism from
like a lot of people? Cuz I don't think
I've ever said that to him. I don't even
know if I like tell him not to talk to
Destiny
>> that there is criticism that I have and
interact with people who
>> Oh no. Oh no. Don't Don't make no
mistake. This is also true. Just some
internet chick. But he's basically like
setting himself on fire to punch me and
make like burn me.
It's [__] up. But I'm getting burned.
Okay. Jesus Christ. It sucks. All right.
He's got the upper ar he's got the upper
body strength of a 10-year-old child.
So, he sets himself on fire when he
throws punches and it's up, man. My
clothes are all burned up.
>> Port like respect Destiny. There's
plenty of criticism on that level.
There's also criticism of that like
people who do not like Destiny are in
the server
and are in my chat. I
I really feel like this is one of those
things where I'm like, "Pisco, be
serious." Right? Like, actually, be
serious for two seconds. Are you getting
these in equal amounts? Pisco, Pisco,
Pisco, are you getting these in even
amounts? Are these like equal? Can we
You be serious? Can you be real? Can you
not be fake right now? It's He's King
Solomon. He's King Solomon right now.
Okay. He's splitting the baby in half.
either because of personal disagreement
with those people because those people
participate
>> in Snork in other places, you know, uh
just Jilk should not be in the server.
Oh, by the way, before he gets into
this, the people who would like most
snark on Destiny are people who were
doxed by Destiny or had their nudes
released by Destiny, just to be clear.
So, like the people who would like post
like that swimsuit picture of him or
whatever on the beach where you like you
should see the the body and those people
those are the people who' like they post
that and I'm like you know what I'm not
going to I'm not going to mod that. I
understand I could mod it. I understand.
I could like try to say no, don't make
fun of his appearance,
but like realistically, I'm sorry, with
Destiny being the person who had either
doxed them first or had like released
nudes of them, released um sorry, videos
of them without their consent. Like
there's a bunch of people like that,
right?
I just I feel like the people who did it
most Yeah. are those people. He should
be out of it. Um you know, not Zip Zip,
but just Tilk. not counterpoints and
Destiny who I I believe was in the
server, but
um Quimman, not Kafka, but any other
number of people. Couldn't Pixie and
Cherry be totally banned in these
spaces? In his spaces?
Uh I think they are. Pixie is mega
snarking. Well, I mean, he started
calling for ICE to arrest Pixie's wife
or something. So me trying to
distinguish
those groups
in virtue of their offserver conduct
necessarily involves me applying
um a rule set beyond the scope of my own
server
and necessarily involves me waiting in
in a dispositive way.
Snip and chase dock are not analogous at
all. No, that's true. Um, that's totally
true. When I was in the Destiny
community, I was the person sitting
there being like, "Dan, you can't do
that here. You ever do some [__] like
that again, you're gone permanently. No
questions asked." Okay, Destiny, I get
that you're like the reason I'm making
the money I'm making right now. You ever
do that [__] again on my server, you're
out of here. No exceptions. Like, I'll
I'll bite that bullet. Don't make me do
it. Right? Like I was the person who as
much as I got run rough shot over, okay,
as somebody who'd only been streaming
for like a year and I wasn't like
prepared for that. I'm nothing like
these people. I You know what the
problem is? Uh the problem is that I
made really easy money before this and
this is also like I'll be honest kind of
easy money. Um and so I don't know. I'm
like I I'll criticize this but I'm
criticizing myself. I
I'm too willing to like sacrifice to
stand on principle. I like didn't learn
enough from the real world. Most people
who have been run over by life will
absolutely just take the money and not
question it. Okay. You're like somebody
who's had like a rough time who's come
from like poverty. They'll like they'll
they just they're like, "You know what?
I should just take the money." Like
realistically.
You know what I'm saying? Uh but I I
stand against that. I guess I don't know
what Zip Zip's excuse is. He's young. He
should be stupid. He should be stupid
and idealistic. And he's he's like
principally he's like principally
unprincipled.
It's very bizarre. It's like the only
thing I can think is like the the
cultlike elements on that front way. And
he's humble too, ladies. I mean, I'm not
like I'm not saying I didn't, but I was
honest as well. People in spicy chat
used to give me like why are you why are
you sweeping for this guy? And I'm like,
honestly, like I feel like he's not a
great person, but probably mostly
financial incentive. Like I'm making
insane money right now. Probably like I
I I can't separate it. I'm a well I'm
well aware I can't separate it that like
I probably should. This was after the
leaks but before the January leaks like
I as far as I know my opinions were
fairly in line with like Queenman or
Chud going into like the first week of
the new year in 2025. I was like, "Well,
I think probably it was done without
consent, but realistically, I feel like
you got to wait on somebody making a
definitive statement who's willing to
pursue something, so I'm kind of
chilling." And I didn't know about any
of the Pixie DMs or the straight raid
leaks or whatever in the background. So,
I was just sitting there like, I'm
saying this and I I can tell people are
getting angrier and angrier about it.
People are getting mad mad mad that I'm
letting it get talked about. And oh, I
wonder where that would have gone if
things hadn't like blown up when they
did.
Jesus,
I got perma banned in here for bringing
up the leaks when they happened. Yeah,
but shut it down. You understand that?
That was for Pixie sake and not for
Destiny, right? That I banned I
literally I don't know if it was like
the next day, but I banned
mentions of any of the victims and then
I said you could talk about the leaks
broadly, but like mentioning like any of
the non-consentual victims, those people
was wrong. Don't do that. Right.
Like I I was like naming people. You
could talk about it in an abstract, but
naming people is awful.
You kick Kelly off the stream one time
and she almost out of pixie. I did do
that. And then she somehow thought she
was really intelligent. Was like, "Oh,
but I I was I can't even remember what
she she's so stupid. Thank god we're
through that era. Holy shit." Um
yeah, I do. Don't even remind me. I
don't want to talk about it, man.
Grontos blew it up a little. Yeah, I
promand him for that. I literally It
wasn't like I'm like, do you think I'm
trying to protect Destiny by not
screaming Pixie's name when she's trying
to deny that she's in the leaks? Do you
think I'm honestly trying to protect
Destiny by doing that? Like, did anyone
could anyone be
for real?
And un like I I just got lucky that uh I
talked to Queen a lot at that time and I
could just be like unfortunately like
right off of his I'm like dude I've got
the same ability as he does. If you've
got criticism like the most unhinged guy
you know won't go and just name Pixie on
stream. Why do you think that is? It's
kind of cuz it's like just objectively
morally wrong to do. It's like
objectively to do. You let him dock
Sunday on your stream yet he wasn't
perma banned. I had some level of
reasoning there for basically I didn't
want to call attention to it and I felt
like what Sunday was doing was drawing
attention to some things
and that he ran on those leaks as soon
as he could. I felt like Sunday had done
some [__] and then he muted Sunday. Um
why I didn't want the leaks run with on
my stream. I didn't want that happen.
Right. It was really, we were having
like a good time and then he started
like just doing the Lawrence Southern
leaks and this was again this is like
stupid but in my mind here's what I'm
thinking right at that time was this
guy's like the victim here. He just had
all these videos leaked or sorry I don't
think I don't think I was like I hadn't
had a chance to go through the videos or
something yet because of when I woke up
and like I was streaming. So while I
think the videos technically had leaked
maybe like an hour a couple hours
earlier that day. I think we didn't even
like Sunday didn't even reference them.
We just didn't know everything that was
there. I think the only thing we really
had a good handle on was the right and
we were like having a good time and then
Sunday just came and killed the vibes.
And I feel like the I was actually
mostly I think kind of annoyed that
Sunday didn't message me, right? Sunday
came in to totally with the stream. He
came in to totally [__] with the stream
and he didn't just shoot me a message
and be like, "Hey, I want to press Desty
on this." which I felt like was super
disrespectful to me. Uh, join the
socialist revolution on Twitch. No,
thank you, dude. Right-wing right-wing
is so much more interesting. Right-wing
populism is so much cooler than uh
leftwing populism. Leftwing like
communism. You guys got like the worst
vibes. Right-wing right-wing dude.
Honestly,
thank god I came and joined these
communities and made like a bunch of
friends here cuz the vibes in like
right-wing populism, right-wing like
nationalism, even white nationalism are
so immaculate right now. Like the the
vapor wave hyperoreian
like esoteric memes. Oh my god. It's
like, dude, the vibes are so good, but I
just don't believe in any of it. It's
like it's so funny. It's so funny to me
in my head and then I'm like but I don't
actually I'm not actually racist enough.
I I wish Dude, if I was racist enough I
could I just make a right now. It's so
cool. Be Canadian Asminol but stronger.
Dude, it's like it's funny stuff. I
don't know how to explain it. I It's
just so cool, man. It's so cool. What
did you think of Pierre Polyv? I thought
he it was overblown how like evil he
was. I thought he's like basically like
a neocon mas. He was like Ronda Santis,
like a neocon. Okay, not Ronda Santis.
There's somebody better. Ronda Santis
was like one of the larers who like
would lar to the point that like he
knows he doesn't belong and he would lar
to the point that he go too far
overboard. That's like Ronda Santis. He
was like a larer who was willing to dog
whistle and like wink wink. He's like um
Ri Priebus or like some of those first
first administration Trump guys who's
like he's like a total neocon at heart
and he's willing to like go like huh
yeah trans people and he like feels
really like he's transgressive and crazy
and then but he's like just dude I need
you to sign this $100 million for Israel
$100 million for Israel $100 million for
Israel right that's that's how I saw
pure polyv was like a total Marco Rubio
I I think even Rubio's a little more
populist than Polyv would be. I think
Polyv was like it was all show. He is
like a conservative policy wonk.
He's like um Oh, he's like Scott Bessant
or something, right? He's like a
conservative policy wonk. He's not he's
he's like a wonk. He is not. And by the
way, Bessant didn't approve of the
global tariffs like anywhere near the
speed they're going and Right. Bessent
is smarter than that. He was a youth
minister under Harper. Yeah, he's like a
total just conservative neocon, small
government, anything guy. Wish we had
more Canadian politics streamers. It's
there's no views in it is the
unfortunate thing. There could be views
in it, but I'd have to work so hard. So,
we'll have to wait until the next cycle.
I'd have to work hard to find out how to
make it funny and interesting, but then
that's like all work you're doing on
yourself. Whereas in American politics,
you can tap into a like a schizosphere
of memes and and
everything. Memes, themes, stories.
ideas. It's just all there and it's like
there's so much material to work with
and Canadian politics. It's like there's
none of that, right? There's just
nothing close.
Also, I would have had a very hard time
discussing Canadian politics and not
like the overton window in Canada on
immigration came to where I was, but I
was way out there on I was like, "Dude,
that you're like actually causing a race
war. You're like explicitly trying to
cause a race war. You're like like this
is every person who thought the great
replacement is real. If they paid two
attention two seconds of attention to
Canadian politics, they go, "Yeah,
there's this this is like the most
zogged out government who's trying to
like it's like all of the elite. They're
trying to destroy this country first.
It's like I swear to God, thank god
conspiratorial populace never discovered
Canadian politics cuz they would have
been like this is a testing ground for
all of their like experimental DEI great
replacement garbage." And I'm, by the
way, I have got no problem with Indian
Canadians, shockingly, okay? Most Indian
Canadians I've met who aren't like fresh
off the boat, brand new here, are
awesome people. Like genuinely awesome
people. Um, and I'm not talking about
like one good one. I'm talking about
like dozens of awesome ones who I've met
like them and their families and they're
cool and they're awesome, right? But
when you bring in that large auh portion
of your population every quarter,
it's insane. Like that, there's no way
you don't have insane social strife. And
I was just like, dude, they're like
actually trying to pop off some kind of
crazy race war in Canada. Ontario,
ground zero for the race war or some I
think it's kind of slowing down now,
though. Right. Right. Am I crazy? Can
anyone confirm who's out in Ontario?
Most of it is students. IMO. Well, yeah.
It just it was wild with like jobs and
housing and it's like putting all of the
wrong pressures on. It's like you're
you're either trying to start a race war
or you're trying to force like some
crazy actual like far-right revolution
in your country. took like the most
popular the most polite country in the
world, the most not the least racist
country in the world, objectively least
racist country in the world and like
tried to experiment with how fast you
could turn them into the like Weimar
Republic overnight. Crazy man. Doug Ford
was content to freeze tuition or
content, sorry, to freeze tuition and
let the colleges import tons of foreign
students for BS certificate programs for
money. Oh, that is the other problem is
that our universities, we might have the
opposite problem of the US where our
universities don't charge enough and so
people get like super cheap educations
but it's all subsidized by international
students who pay like 10x what regular
students pay. So like while you do get a
cheap education, it's like pretty cool,
you do need like a steady supply of
students to keep the system afloat,
which is not great. I don't understand
why it would be that hard or how it's
that hard to just open more medical
schools in Canada and basically tie like
your I don't know
>> how do we not have I I feel like that
would be an interesting question for
Canada specifically like what prevents
Canada from opening up like 50 new
medical schools
like just being like we have to actually
max out our med schools get as many
doctors trained as possible and flood
this like I understand slowing it down
slightly or or like lowering standards
slightly might have some negative
consequences, but bro, we need more
doctors.
Maybe you don't have the teachers for
it. Maybe. Yeah, that could be a
bottleneck. Teachers for it. But like
realistically, man. I don't know. We're
subsidized by foreign students as well.
It's just really expensive anyway. Yeah,
but you guys are all subsidizing like
your college NFL that exists. [__]
wild. The quality dilution of quality.
The quality is already worse than you
think it is. Well, I've described how my
doctor is, right? I've described my
doctor. Oh, I think I don't have her
anymore. I got a doctor who was like
straight from Pakistan. Couldn't speak
English. Actually could not speak
English at all. Like I would literally
It was It was wild when I first went in.
I'm like, "Here's my prescription."
She's like, "Oh yes, this is good." And
I'm like, "I want more of that." And
she's like, "Yes, I'd give more here.
This good? Yeah. Uh, maybe a little
more." Yeah. Okay. Okay. That's a good
dose. Thank you. It's like, okay, this
is a little weird. I'm flying by the
seat of my pants here. [__] that, dude.
I'm overstating it, but I'm overstating
it by like 10%. You think I'm like
overstating it by a thousand%. I'm
overstating it by like 10%. Like
literally, I'm like, "No, no, no. You
need to give me this." And she's like,
"I need to rule is we do blood work
first." And I'm like, "No, just" and
she's like, "No, blood work. Blood blood
work. Okay, whatever. Go get the blood
work done." And she's like, "Okay, what
do you need? What do you need?"
Uh, long time it was South Asian
Medical. Um, I went back to like my
childhood doctor. It's like hours away,
but he does do like tea health. So, and
he's South African. Very smart guy. So,
very cool. Very cool. I'm I think I'm
back with him now. So, well, I am back
with him. I don't know why I say I think
I am back with him. This isn't what's
happening. This isn't what's happening.
This is This is too much. This is too
much. That's not it. That's not a thing.
Sorry, we went off way. We went way off
track with some talk about Canadian
politics. Whoa. Boy, we should finish
this Pisco content and then I should uh
dip the out. Don't have doctors to teach
them. You'll crash incomes. Okay. But
like that's that's a um that's like a
curve problem, right? Like how fast we
ramp. That's like a curve problem. Like
you just you literally just do a little
bit. We need to add two more medical
schools. Okay, let's see how that goes.
We need to add two more medical school
medical schools now. Okay, let's see how
that goes
>> on the issues.
>> You said 15x. I know I said I said
I said like 20 new or 15 new medical
schools, but it's like you understand it
being hyperbolic. Like that's a
I maybe I speak in a way that's hard to
figure out or something, right? But like
I do just mean we need to add more. And
I would risk adding a little bit too
much, but we should just adding more.
Just get to adding more and break some
things to make make it so you can add
more and then figure out if you need to
add more. Go just go just go do
something. Do anything
>> that I do not want.
Doesn't seem like dollar is going to be
worth very much. How about you just
borrow? Okay, everybody's kind of trying
to be like responsible, fiscally
responsible. Hey, tomorrow doesn't
exist. Let's just borrow. Let's just go
Japanese with it. Okay. Hey, Canada.
Hey, Canadians everywhere. Let's
Let's go for austerity.
Austerity in like every way except
infrastructure and education spending.
Okay, we're maxing out science for the
next like 20 years and living a very
lean lifestyle. Okay, and then we'll see
what happens. And we'll borrow we'll
borrow like we're in East Asia. Let's do
it. Let's go
to Wade into which are not interesting
for me to wait into which don't
necessarily
unless forced.
>> It's not it's not debt maxing
necessarily. It's just like, dude, be
ahead of the curve. Like, cuz just
borrow, man. I understand interest rates
are a little high. Trump's about to
totally boil the economy.
Get ahead of the curve. Let's go.
>> Certain accusations
bear on the conduct that happens in the
server. So, what is being requested of
me is not to apply my own rules about
how I want to run the stuff.
>> Is this like a thing, dude? Where's uh
where's Marty Epstein? Marty Epstein
around? He's probably gone home for
Christmas. haven't seen Marty Epstein
around the last little while. Is that a
thing where like even though interest
rates are up with how fast inflation's
rising, how fast like the dollar is
devaluing, is that a thing that
borrowing would still be as valuable?
Feels like no, because of like like
rates are a different metric. But no,
but like as inflation kind of like goes
higher and the dollar devalues more
significantly, then that would cut into
the interest rate, wouldn't it? Think he
was around tonight? I didn't see him
tonight.
There's like a concept there that I
can't grasp on to because I am sleepd
deprived.
Marty here tonight. Marty was not here
tonight. Marty hasn't been here in a
while. Marty hasn't been talking in a
while, but Marty was here just like two
or three nights ago donating insane
amounts of money. So,
>> in my servers talking for a little bit,
>> but some other rules,
some other sets of things. And it's not
clear to me other than
satisfying
the preferences of other people why that
should happen. Why should I
accept?
>> I think I also think that you can have
these reasons, but doesn't this like
look worse that you haven't looked into
why do [__] I hate I hate criticizing
this guy cuz it feels like a little
dising like it feels rough when he's got
so many people who are willing to come
in and just tell him how he should do
everything. Okay.
But man, he uh it feels like you could
say all of this like, "Oh, we want to
give everybody a chance. we want to like
do things fairly and then it's like but
you still say you haven't looked into
why doobie is banned
>> to the extent that it affects the server
the community that I want to build
#
>> why is it correct
why is it good that rather than give
everyone a chance in my server
I don't do that people say what about
gropers okay
uh
Um,
>> well, if a Groper wants to come into the
server and they break the server rules,
>> dude, you say this, but like you say
this, but how many rules did Doobie
break?
How many rules has Destiny's community
broken?
Like, I'm sorry. They're like, it's
[__] up. Listen, I I get it.
Everybody's equal. We get votes. We're
equal. We just have to go to our own
water fountain. Okay, there's the
there's the coloreds water fountain over
there for the snarker types and the
whites only water fountain over here for
the DG sphere people. Okay, you go over
to your colors only fountain. You drink
from there. I get it.
>> Oh, you drank from the whites only
fountain. That's a ban. That's a ban.
>> That's ban. You're done.
>> Violated the rules.
>> You're out. I I By the way, I say that
mostly I guess in [__] These mods are
nice to me. It's just the it's the vibe
I get sometimes.
>> That's called debate.
>> Yeah, we have MAGA people in the server
that I talk to all the time. If there is
some intentional,
you know, indication I'm intentionally
fostering it, by which I mean actively
trying to create a community of a
specific thing.
>> Dude, I'm just going to say it one more
time because I have to. Okay, I have to.
The situation last night, we're
listening to Pisco talk to D to what's
his name? Zip Zip. The only
conversations we're having is around
what Zip Zip was just like blatantly
lying about his conversation with Pisco
trying to trying to gaslight us and
pretend that he wasn't totally wrong in
everything he was saying. Okay. Uh but
we talked about that and the second
somebody tried to switch over to Destiny
drama, we dipped. I dipped Queen and I
think it dipped before, but I dipped. I
was like, "Dude, I don't want I don't
want to talk about that Pisco server."
He said he doesn't want to hear.
Contrast our actions with the actions of
the Destiny community trying repeatedly
to record that VC Destiny coming in and
talking non-stop about his [__] Like
like dude, it's not close. And if I was
doing that, well, I wouldn't do that.
Sharp might be Sharp would probably give
me some kind of benefit of the doubt,
but god damn. And I do know there are
some people from my community who are in
the FC listening, but I told them not
to. Okay, I told them not to. I think my
wand was in there, but I don't control
that person, dude. Come on, man. I don't
control them. They're on their own. I
missed the memo. Yeah, I got it. Uh,
anyway, so I But I didn't I didn't
support that. I tried to explicitly pull
people away from that so that we weren't
doing that there. At least most of the
all the snarker types weren't there.
Okay, the snarker types were having a
conversation about the new Marvel
trailers that got leaked.
>> All right, that's where that's what we
were doing.
Very cool.
>> All right, that I totally understand.
>> That's just to me it's like the double
standard of the rules, right?
>> And the criticism from that,
>> that is not my intent to cultivate a
server of MAGA people or a server of
snarkers or a server of
racist members of the KKK.
>> Dude, none of the gripers who come and
sit in the kick chat ever join the
Discord. It's kind of [__] up. They
they're they're Discord avoidant.
>> Very unfortunate. That's not my goal at
all.
>> He just looked at his chat. He just
looked at his chat
>> and in no sense.
>> He just looked at his chat and a bunch
of people are saying, "Why is Doobie
banned?" And he didn't acknowledge it.
Are we going to pretend we can't see
this guy looking at his chat? I know he
read his chat. I know for a fact he read
his chat. Some people say that this guy
reads his chat all the time.
>> Is this for money?
>> Oh, this is this is cope.
>> Cope in the way you think. first of all,
who is banned from my server for a
reason I don't even know. I give a lot
of autonomy to my mods to to be
empowered to enforce the rules. So, I
don't even know the basis of Dubbie's
ban. I think I asked maybe once or twice
and didn't follow up because I just
didn't have an interest. You can ask
Dubbie like whether or not he's
unbanned.
Doobie is banned. But the point is,
Dubbie can spend as much money as he
wants donating in my
uh super chats
and it will not fundamentally change
anything about who I am or how I want to
run my server. At most, it'll be like,
"Okay, guys, uh, you know,
fundamentally, no." at the margins, it
could definitely change things.
Especially
like I don't I don't know Pisco's
financial situation. Okay. But I assume
he's got like a war chest of some kind
that he could operate off of. Um piece
of evidence. He seems to have started
doing this as a job. He was pretty lax
about it at points when he started. I
think if he was like really hurt up for
money, he would be streaming a lot more.
Would have been streaming a lot more
back then. He seemed pretty consistent
now, but I think he would have been
streaming a lot more back then. Okay.
So, I do think that probably got a bit
of a war chest built up. Not concerned
about money. If he was heard up, if he's
hurting for money,
>> I do think it could affect
>> donated $3. Hello,
>> Doobie. Please donate to me instead.
>> Don't donate to anyone else. Oh, except
me. Me.
Thank you for the donation, Dung Devil.
Appreciate it, buddy. Okay.
Oh, what was I saying here? Oh, it could
affect you. So, that's a little bit of
coke there. Maybe not. It won't like
change his opinion drastically, but it's
a little at the margins would affect
things.
>> Is he what what's happened with his ban?
He's like donated a lot of money. Like,
should he be banned?
>> Yeah, this is basically what I'm saying
straight right. But I think he's saying
fundamentally like it wouldn't change
his fundamental views. And I do think
that's true. Like you're not going to
you're not going to donate Pisco into
being a communist. I just don't think
it's going to happen.
>> And I didn't even follow up, right? It's
the proof in the pudding. I think
probably just as a matter of fairness
you should follow up. But hey, he
donated all this money and I didn't even
I wasn't even fair to him. That's not
that's not like cool. That's not You're
kind of just describing being an even
money can't make me not be an [__]
and if he wants to donate to me. My
question is
>> I that's yeah I do think this is true
that in terms of having your principles
be tested. I think Pisco's stood tall in
a situation I've watched a lot of people
falter in at least to like an extent
that nobody else really does or has.
Like I see a lot of people falter in
that precise situation totally. He's
been tested and it's like
and to no benefit. no immediate benefit
whatsoever.
It manifests in the way that you're less
likely to say certain things. Yeah.
Yeah. Yeah. This is more what it is. Is
like if I know
if I know I've got Matt NLT gifting me
10 subs every other night, maybe I go,
it's not as good. Actually, it's good.
You know,
>> happens.
>> Why shouldn't I accept it? What is the
reason that I shouldn't accept his
money?
I'm not it's not a exchange, right? In
that I'm not providing him any service
or any promise or any action.
>> Like it's not a quid proquo. Let's go.
>> In virtue of what?
>> I'm the opposite. Hey, if you're banned
and you want to be unbanned from
something, $5, $15, that's you can
always pay out. Is it wrong for me to
just
>> Now you guys are Now you guys are in a
terrible situation because I've got all
this free time to spend in the Discord,
spend in the community. I can like hang
out and do whatever I want. So, I'm just
around to like start timing people out
and collecting my money. How much to
free Ozel? Um
um
I don't know. I don't Yeah, I don't
know.
We'll see.
>> Let the donation or whatever from
anyone, right,
>> occur as opposed to why I ought to go in
there and like refund it or ban them or
somehow try to prevent the the donations
from happening at all.
>> Uh I know you'll be I know maybe you'll
be good Ozel. No, hold on. You say
you'll be good, Ozel. I know you'll
eventually threaten to kill somebody
again. And so it's just like
can I handle that those optics right
now?
I don't know, man. I don't know
>> why.
But this is further to the point. The
point is
>> Ozel is like very similar to Brown is
humor except like way more subtle as in
he'll like change his username for a
millisecond or like post a message and
then delete it instantly saying
something that he knows that he would
get banned for. And he thinks he's very
clever.
>> Even putting that aside, if he's not
make like sending me money,
this is poulry amounts. Why would you
think my reputation my uh what what I
stand for like my values are worth like
such cheap trifling amounts of money?
It's a thousand bucks he gave the other
stream and then I think he gave uh you
know over the course I don't even know
if I had to make a guess over the course
it's probably something
>> probably g like five grand
>> I don't know 1,800 bucks over the course
of the entire time I've had um
monetization which is like less than a
year.
>> Oh really? I would have thought it was
like at least two or three grand. But
no, but here's the thing straight away.
Here's Pisco's equation and why it's
like this is all he has to say is I as a
lawyer
am probably looking at you know in five
years like 300 to $500,000 total
compensation. And I know he probably
doesn't want to say that to people,
right?
But like I'd say 5 to 10 years he's
looking at $300 to $500,000 a year
compensation. That's probably what he's
looking at as like a huge lawyer in the
most expensive city in the in one of the
biggest most expensive cities in the
world. Probably somewhere in there.
Okay. That's like if he had to
compromise himself to do this job, he
could just go back to law. Um law law
firms like the ones he worked at, which
I'm not going to get specific on, they
don't not take people back. They're not
like, "Oh no, you you up. you like
really no like to to get to where he got
to as quickly as he did, there's like
something there that people will pull
you back in, right? So that's what his
equation is and he can't really be
changed. And there's also the idea. So
there's like short-term, medium-term,
long-term money-m.
Short-term money-making, he could
compromise a little bit, but long-term
money-making, you're on YouTube, you've
got like connections to a bunch of big
political creators. You go for the
long-term plan of just building out your
personality, your community, your your
everything. And you just let people
flock in, right? You let them filter
into you. That's what you do. Okay.
Obviously,
>> what I'm going to for 1,800 bucks
doesn't even make sense. There's not a
single thing position I've taken that or
stance I have on anything that is
informed by those poulry sums of money.
You know what would make me more money
is if I just read the room and just gave
people what they wanted to hear.
>> Oh, this is the part that I thought was
cope where he's like, "Oh, wouldn't it
make me way more money if I just
pandered to DG?"
I think you would have to be
shortsighted to think that it could make
you shortsighted money. It could make
you short-term money. Um, but I do not
think that's a long-term solid game
plan.
Like for better or worse, the really
intelligent people will look at someone
like like Destiny or that community and
they'll go, "Oh, that's like a total
freak show I need to avoid." Right.
Which is the call Pisco just made. Like
I can't have these people be talked
about. It's too much.
Yeah. So like you just want to be away
from it. So like appealing to those
people just like Yeah. totally cocking
to those people. There is no real
long-term money to be made in it.
Especially if you look at it from the
point of view of like why did Vos and
Hassan make the same decision about just
getting away was cuz those people are
never going to let you be the bigger
figure. Right? Ultimately
trying to make those people happy. Pisco
just watched. He just went through the
ritual of trying to make those people
happy. Watching that he observing that
he clearly had the better ideas. He
clearly had the more solid position.
Nobody could raise a serious objection.
They basically tone policed in a way
that they never apply that standard back
on their own community or the creator
they support. It's like, oh, they're
just like trying to correct me or
something because they disagree with
their creator, but they can't defend
that position why they want to correct
me. They can't defend trying to correct
me at all. And then they can't even
defend supporting the other creator in
his position against me. Like, it's it's
like embarrassing. Why would you ever
try to Why would you ever try to court
an audience that by definition if you're
ever even on even if you're correct,
they will try to tear you down for being
correct if it's against the person they
support, right? Like as much as I know
this community can ra like rag on re
sometimes, I love having Really around
because he's at least willing to come in
and argue like strenuously like in a
stressful way against the rolling of the
community. my opinion, he's willing to
like stand up on the thing he believes,
right? Even if even if I don't think
he's informed, even if I think like,
"Oh, I think you're wrong and I think
it's kind of weird that you're even
standing." He'll at least come and do
it. And
he won't like I don't need you guys like
I'll try to I'll try to build him up for
doing that. Like I don't need you guys
to tear him down. If I think I'm
correct, I'll just let my I'll just try
to be correct. I don't want my community
to go tear him down because my ego is
too small to admit he might be right.
Like that's stupid. It's gay. I can't
imagine doing that to a friend. Like I
think I'm wrong or I know I'm wrong or I
can't muster any argument and then I try
to get my community to go and like tear
them down
is nuts. All I hear is DEI hire. How
about you? All you hear is one of the
only people with the balls to hop on the
stream when Destiny's threatening to dox
people who associate with me. Do you
think about that?
one of the only people who's on that
side who would even bother coming on
stream.
>> Okay. Oh well, you say you're joking,
but unfortunately I'm gonna have to
stand up business on this and just say
it's like crazy that a lot of people
hate on the guy even when he's wrong.
Like I get that he could be wrong. I get
that he could be wrong, but I don't have
to like tear him down. And he's also
he's made good points in other
conversations. So again, even if I if
like there was a conversation where
people I can't remember which oh the
Hassan one about like rapegate or
whatever like I think most people
thought he won that conversation. I
didn't go and tell people like [__] this
guy. He's such a piece of [__] I was
like oh here's where I like went wrong
in the conversation. I went down like
some blind alley I didn't even really
want to talk about cuz I think it was
about the Hila. It was like about the
Hila Klein raids into Ramala thing,
right? and I let it go down a different
alley. And it's like, dude, why would I
ever tell my community to like go after
Rei because I think he won a debate
against me? It would be like an insane
thing to do. I don't know. Or why would
I let it happen? Be crazy. Anyway,
>> you know how I would do really, really,
really well? It's called picking a lane.
That's what makes me a ton of money,
obviously, is to not upset members of my
own community with
>> Yeah, this is cope. I hope he doesn't
actually think this. that makes you a
lot of money in the very short term. But
I thought I hope he doesn't actually
think that's the more profitable thing
because he has he has the right idea. Or
maybe it doesn't matter if he thinks
he's following his principles so that's
going to make him the most money or
sorry so he's going to make less money.
No, no, no. Following your principles,
being consistent and having a story you
can build up over time that will make
you the most amount of money. Okay. By
far. not to some other audience that
doesn't like you, that doesn't like you,
and especially doesn't like double
doesn't like you if you disagree with
somebody they like more.
>> Endless conversations, six, seven,
eight, nine conversations they don't
want to hear
>> about a topic that they disagree with me
on.
>> Dude, that was Oh man, that was like the
other crazy thing was I can tell why
they got so mad. I got a chance to hear
a little bit. Okay, I got to hear a
little bit of
what Queman was saying. Quean was
spitting in the Pisco Discord. He said
like 10 sentences tops over hours,
right?
>> But Pisco's like literally kind of
getting like he's kind of dumbfounded at
some point where they're like
criticizing him on tone. They're
basically being like, "Yeah, so like
you're sort of right on everything, but
like you kind of seem like mean
sometimes." And he's like, "Wait, you're
like destiny orbiters. You're like,
you're like Destiny Orbiters. You're
saying I'm being mean. You came into and
Quimman Cunning and he's like, "No, you
don't understand, Pisco. These people
only respect strength." Like, actually
start telling them they're morons. Don't
do not sit here and pretend that they're
actually listening to the ideas. They
only hear strength. They only respect
strength. Tell them they're so they'll
admit they're wrong. And I'm like,
"Yes." Like, actually, actually true.
Okay, that's so insanely true right now
that these people they need the tone
indicator. They need the alpha tone
indicator. Hey, remember how you're like
a total who's not worth anything and you
have to suck up to people who are better
than you because you have nothing to say
on your own. Remember that? You need
that tone indicator. Okay, you need that
that tone indicator for people so they
can know their place in the hierarchy
like what these people are.
>> It's so it's so annoying, but I was
like, "Yeah, that is exactly what it is.
Yeah, do the tone indicator. It's Oh,
but also when you're really out of place
and you try to do the tone indicators
like Destiny does, it's so cringe, dude.
I was talking to Zip Zip and trying to
get him to explain why Pisco was totally
wrong in their conversation. And he's
like trying to talk to me. He's like,
"You'd know this if you weren't so
stupid." And I'm like, "Yes, I'm very
stupid." Zip Zip, do you want to answer
that question? He's like, "Well, I could
answer the question, but you're just
like too dumb to understand." I'm like,
"Yeah, I'm too dumb to understand. Could
you break it down for me?" Like like,
bro, could you just It's so funny that
they're like, "You're you're so much
more dumb than me." Okay, you could say
that. Could you just get to the actual
part of the conversation I care about? I
literally don't care about your opinion.
Just tell me what you were saying. My
god,
>> it's not even sensible to think that
there's a a financial motivation here. A
because the sums of here like what the
Stark communities,
I don't know how many people follow
those accounts.
>> Stark Brookies.
>> Is it even close?
I hear they be snarking on cuz you got
the money that they don't. Okay. Broies
be snarking on all day to anything that
Destiny's sizes.
>> If I if I truly my only motivation was
to make money.
>> So it doesn't make sense on on the on a
financial side and my opinions aren't
explained by that. You know, I obviously
gave my opinion on uh the lawsuit and on
the the per stuff before I like was
financially benefited from it.
to the extent that I was and I don't
think I was. I thought I was hurt from
it.
Stunts growth, lose subscribers, review
bombs.
It hurts me on that. Doesn't help me.
And so what's the issue? What is the
issue?
>> What is the issue?
>> The issue is I don't even think this is
really about like the argument regarding
my personal incentives. I don't really
think it's about actually making a case
that my opinions are being fed to me.
>> It's about the idea that you're going to
say that you should only hold someone
culpable for what you can prove they
did. That's the true that is the true
problem in the liberal fascist era,
okay? Where these these people have
totally abandoned, you know, innocent
till proven guilty any form of like,
well, you know, we we know this
happened, right? This has been admitted
to, so we can punish this person for
this. Right? Here's their admission.
Here's like the evidence. We've we've
totally forgotten that. Nope. Don't need
to do that anymore, guys. Guess what? It
came divine revelation. We just get to
do whatever we want. Let's go.
>> Like the, you know, the Spongebob where
>> Jesus Christ.
>> Which one was it? They have like
something in their hat. They're getting
instructions. Is it the driving test?
And they floor it.
>> Okay. With your Spongebob reference. My
god. I forget what it is. What are you
doing?
>> It's about feeling. It's about feelings
of people genuinely feeling hurt,
feeling betrayed, feeling sad, angry,
>> feeling like things are unfair. And I
believe that a lot of those feelings are
sincerely held.
I I I really do think that a lot of
those feelings are sincerely held. Now,
I hope that people can respect that I
have different feelings, too. I don't
express all my feelings that I have out
of u for different reasons that I think
are good reasons, but I don't doubt the
sincerity of the people who um who say
they like feel hurt by what I say or um
what I'm doing. I don't doubt the
sincerity of those feelings. And I can
argue till I'm blue in the face that
they're not right to have those feelings
in my opinion. The feeling, for example,
that I'm drifting, I think that that's
not a justified feeling, but or that I'm
going to turn into I don't think that's
a justified feeling. Or the feeling that
um I'm actively trying to hurt Destiny.
I don't think it's justified feeling.
The feeling that I'm actively trying to
encourage my community, smart community,
I can't like say that I have any ability
to affect the sincerity of those
feelings based on me just dragging
people into voice chat to make
arguments. It's not really about that.
And I don't want to claim that I'm the
most clear person whenever I talk and
that I have like
>> I will say I do wish at some point I
wish I could have talked to Pisco in the
small moment where he was willing to
talk about this and just say I really
wish if people were going to say this
happened, you would challenge them or
you could because I I feel like getting
him to litigate it, he was somebody who
can't be pushed. He's like too
committed to looking at things from like
a legal sense, from like a like a legal
perspective. I just wish I could have
gotten him to look at the whole thing
and just see like how they have
literally nothing, like absolutely
nothing
that corresponds to why Destiny started
doxing people, right? Destiny started
doxing people in like March of 2025.
The first thing he actually has that's
tangible in any way I think
is I think is the Oh, it's like uh they
say we celebrated Rose getting doxed.
Well, I don't think that's true. I think
people celebrated that like Destiny got
made to look like a complete by doxing
Rose and proving that she was a minor
when he her
through a third party, right?
And then the next thing is the cyber
thing and that's like seven months later
after he doxed like a half dozen people
>> like a a good awareness of
communicating myself well to people who
are maybe like just not they don't know
the words I I use many big word instead
of few small word I have plenty of
communication issues that are well
documented
in virtue of the fact that sometimes we
have issues communicated or I or me
understand
>> the Kelly Lolena stuff the telling
Lolena stuff is like extremely obviously
exculpatory for my community. And now
that Lena is seemingly maybe not that
cool with Destiny, maybe she just
explained that like I literally was
like, "Hey, it seems like your partner
there is like trying to dox me." She's
like, "Yeah, I know it's really and I
just really hope that uh you understand
how much it means to me that you'll like
call Kelly out when she tries to do
these like collateral attacks on me."
And then I get Destiny GOING, "THIS GUY
TARGETS MY GIRLFRIEND. THIS GUY targets
my And I'm like, "Dude, why don't you
ask your girlfriend what she thinks?"
>> Sandy, what is being said? And I have to
have things repeated to me. I'm not
perfect on that score.
>> I think we pulled this up already. The
rig doll thing. Hold on. I think it's
the rig doll thing.
>> What can I do if
>> all I do?
>> No. Twitter. Buying a plushy of a does
not mean you romanticize, glamorize, or
fetishize
>> the plushy.
>> Two of those genuinely felt feelings of
betrayal.
>> He retweeted it. I'm sure he did.
something immoral. I'm turning,
>> you know, going back on my principles
when I think I'm upholding them, right?
If all
>> that's
guys, it's all me.
>> I do. It will never satisfy. I promise.
I promise. So, I could ban just
any Destiny critic from my discord. I
could do that. And in so doing, would I
have acquiesed it um to feelings that I
think are unjustified? No doubt. In some
ways, I've already done that. We'll get
to the rule change eventually. I'm a
yapper. In some ways, I've already done
that. In response to the previous
socialism conversation, we may adjust
the rule basically say, "Hey, let's keep
it focused. Let's not, you know, go too
much into personalities." That's an, you
know, that's acquiescing. That's
something I wouldn't otherwise do. Not
everyone gets that rule change. We don't
do that for Trump streamers. We don't do
that for the average streamer because
I'm sensitive to the feelings. I'm
sensitive. There's a lot of overlap in
our audiences. I could cut off all ties
with anyone with whom Destiny doesn't
have a good relationship. I could do
that.
>> What? No, don't do that.
>> I could never ever again criticize a
position of Destiny's or not do so in
certain ways.
>> I could if I wanted to.
Dude, I like that he's basically he's
entirely ruled out the concept of having
like a good faith conversation when he
disagrees with this community or their
streamer. Like that's totally gone out
of his mind, right? He's like, "Here are
the options I've got. I tried the good
faith way. That clearly failed in every
possible manner.
>> Say the words that people want me to
hear and wade into uh a lawsuit on a
particular side. I could I could do
that." But there the problem is, hey,
it's not going to satisfy everybody cuz
>> Did you notice that this PC PSA is only
happening after esports Batman and JTO
and the rest of the community came and
started talking about H3/Destiny drama?
Oh, that's actually totally wrong,
right? That's actually like a total lie.
Like literally, I didn't talk about this
drama at all. Pisco was there for most
of the time I was in his VC. I didn't
even speak. I was just listening. I
didn't even unmute my mic to laugh
audibly. I just left my mic muted and
played Civ and listen to him tear strips
out of Zip Zip like a psychopath. Okay.
Like a psychopathic wolverine just like
gore. turning this guy into gore
was very interesting, very funny. Okay,
>> cuz a lot of it won't be sincerely done.
It's it's done out of fear because of
course the underlying assertations are
not true and people can tell
>> Civ 7
>> when you're being sincere and when
you're under a gun. The other problem is
I don't want to I don't want to unless
there's a good reason
>> just acquies for its own sake to deal
with emotions at and sincerely held ones
genuine emotions. I just feel like
people who say that they're going to dox
people in your discord, people who have
doxed a lot of people who are around
your community, former friends of yours,
and then they're like, "Actually, your
community is open season 2." I think
probably people who are going to like
green light, who are going to co-sign
that you shouldn't have around for the
safety of your community, but hey, and
by the way, they do it out in the open.
They do it like directly. Um, it's
obvious it's them. And then they go,
"Well, but you let Jay talk here and he
doxes people." It's like, "Okay,
evidence. Evidence, please.
>> Uh, I'm gonna loop on this forever.
>> I don't have any purchase on what's
actually occurring in my head
>> because if I do that, if I just do it
because even when I think it's
unjustified,
>> Queman wasn't even The funny thing is is
like Quimman wasn't even being
opportunistic. Queman could have been
way worse in that debate. The thing that
I'm sure upset Zip Zip the most is that
when Quimman did talk, from what I heard
when he did talk, it was just to be like
to basically try to explain in a
different way, in a rudder way, what
Pisco was saying. And every time he
spoke up, every time Bloomman spoke up,
Pisco go, "Yeah, like what exactly that
guy said." Could you imagine a zip zip?
You've sat here just being like this
totally spineless loser supporting these
people no matter what they do or say.
And then Quimman comes in the most
abrasive, obnoxious in all of internet
commentary. And Pisco's like, "Oh yeah,
I'm vibing with this guy."
Oh. Oh, you could just you could almost
feel it.
What good am I? If there are violations
of server rules in my server, we will
enforce them strictly. doxing and we'll
get into the rule change eventually. Um,
harassment.
>> Wait a minute. Sorry. That was his only
response. That was his only response. I
can't hear you through your accent.
>> Well, luckily Kisco can hear me to
high-five me. Good luck.
>> We will enforce them. 100%.
As we always have strived to do.
Violations of toss the same. What I'm
not going to do is be bullied.
>> I It's okay. He's being bullied
into making the decision that's best for
him. Okay. I do, but like h it's like
such a I probably shouldn't even quibble
on it, but like that's why Destiny did
let his community do that. That's why he
did go and participate. That's why he
did go and litigate the drama that you
didn't want litigated there, right? The
only time I litigated stuff in your
Discord, and I think this is another
thing that he was kind of responding to
was when I thought you guys were
basically saying that this harassment
thing happened. I was just like, "Oh,
you guys could provide evidence if you
like." No evidence exists.
No evidence exists of anything they've
like claimed ex anything that they've
claimed exists. Right. So, oh, also I
can go to like Wix Wix Discord and talk
about it now. I think they talk about it
a lot too. Adopting something a position
or a standard that isn't based in
anything consistent, any good reason,
any justifiable purpose
other than acquiescence and
acknowledgement. Now I say that that
said my interests have in fact you know
changed in virtue of recent events
and let me give you an example of this.
So obviously we've had this discussion
about the Ethan Klein lawsuit and that
has generated feelings of um negativity
that like I'm somehow trying to appeal
to snark communities who generally
support the defendants and the destiny
community which generally supports
plaintiff. And it's in that context that
that I've had my opinion and that
opinion people have been able to see it
develop in real time from the very
beginning when I watched it for the
first time just in because my editor
sent me the video and said this might be
interesting. Let's experiment, right?
Like you're you're doing a lot of legal
analysis from the Trump perspective.
Let's see if people like it when you
talk about these other prominent
lawsuits. So I do so and then the people
can see the push back what I respond to
and how I respond to it. Unlike a lot of
other people, I am someone who always
wants to hear the and defend it. and I'm
just thinking out loud. That's one of
the I think the secret weapons or
whatever that I I utilize a lot of these
conversations. Maybe that's one of the
reasons why I think that's it's more
plausible people like they don't see
their chats is because I'm just thinking
out loud. When you hear my thoughts in
the nature of a conversation, I might
have some idea about where I want to go
generally, but I'm actually listening to
the other side and thinking out loud and
everyone can witness and see in real
time. Dude, it's like it's actually
crazy
that like our our communities, the the
snark communities like let Pisco talk
and his they they listen. It's like are
there enjoying like the the the
conversation Pisco wants to have and
then we leave and we're like I didn't
like Pisco's argument here. And then
and then the DG attack isn't I didn't
like Pisco's argument here. I didn't
like Pisco's argument there. The DG
attack is Pisco is hanging out with
Queenman and Jtock in a VC. I guess if
he just wants to be a part of those
communities, then he's an evil now and
he's green lit for any attack. It's like
uh what about the arguments, man? What
about the argument? Wait, why did you
did you disagree, fam? Like what? Just
explicitly only guilt by association
here. Okay, there is no other argument.
Okay, what kind of what kind of American
are you? What? What are Where are you
from? America. Yeah, but like what kind
of America? What's the line from Civil
War? What kind of American are you? Oh,
Jesus. This scene's forever. I just want
the line, bro. Can you chill?
>> We're American journalists.
>> You told me that already.
>> Okay. We
>> We work for Reuters.
>> Reuters doesn't sound American.
>> It's a news agency.
>> I know what Reuters is,
>> sir. Okay. I'm just saying.
>> Just saying. Just what?
>> You're American. Okay.
>> Okay.
What kind of American are you? Central
American.
>> Uh I thought isn't there like a That
can't be it, right? There's got to be
more than that. Is that really the line?
I thought he delivered it differently.
Oh well, whatever. Yeah, I heard I think
this movie sucks. I think the movie the
concept was good. I think it sucked
completely. Heard it sucked completely.
Too bad.
>> My opinion develop on the Ethan Klein
lawsuit. They can watch it. They're all
available. Every conversation, the hours
and hours of people, contrary to the
implication that was being made that
I've had no uh exposure whatsoever to
the relevant clips related to the saga,
just preposterous. Everyone here knows
that's a lie. Everyone here knows that
you can go back into all my VODs and see
people bringing clips to my attention.
can see me spending hours talking about
this issue, dealing with its crit the
criticisms at its strongest,
not shying away from it, trying futile,
naively, some might say in the hope
perhaps that um either my opinion is
adopted or at least people can say it's
a genuine held opinion. Naively saying
reason will prevail and you don't have
to agree with my reason, but naively
saying reason will prevail. Maybe if I
just explain myself, maybe if I just get
this person to see my logic, to see what
I'm thinking about it, maybe they can at
least accept that we have a
disagreement. It's sincerely held
naively, innocently, right? And that's
what happened in this last week. You
know,
I I love Hutch. Hutch is my boy. I
respect Hutch. Hutch expressed he wanted
to have this conversation. And I also
wanted to have the conversation. Hutch
knows what I'm like. Everyone knows what
I'm like. I'm just thinking out loud. I
haven't changed. When I have these
debates, you know, some you catch me in
a different mood, I might feel a little
different. Last night on Discord VC, I
was a little bit more chippy and more
uh, you know, relaxed some, you know,
doing more jokes.
>> I be so for real right now. Pisco, I I'm
pretty sure
I'm pretty sure this guy had sparked a
doobie or something. Okay, speaking of
doobie, this guy sparked a doobie or
something before he got in that car. I
He was so happy golucky, laughing his
ass off at everything.
I'm pretty sure this guy was there was
something going on there. Okay, this guy
was he was giggling,
>> but he knows fundamentally what this is.
>> He was giggling.
>> Hutch and I have these encounters every
week.
Everyone sees it. This is not some
special thing. Everyone knows my
demeanor in these conversations. They
know how I talk to Rob No and how I talk
to um uh you know, different people come
on the stream like you know other
examples. You don't need examples. Even
does I when we argue about the judiciary
stuff and what have you. Everyone knows
that's how I am and so does Hutch. And
so Hutch is not surprised or maybe you
can tell me. You know, I don't have any
basis to think he's surprised when he
walks in the conversation and I act like
I always act.
If anything, I I think I'm I'm trying to
be more like trying to build a
foundation. It's why I start where I
where I start. Like, do you care to have
this conversation? Do you agree it's
important to have this conversation?
It's me trying to to establish a mutual
understanding. And maybe I didn't do the
best at at having that done. I tried. I
can tell you I gave it an honest effort.
>> Okay. Okay. Like maybe Pisco didn't do
the best job of like trying to get on
the same page. But the suggestions these
dudes had for Pisco were like, have you
thought about just like going down the
blind alley and having that
conversation, then going back and
redoing it if it all up? Like just have
a conversation about something you don't
care to discuss for like 15 minutes.
It's like, dude, get the out of here.
Like actually, literally go make your
own channel. No, you want to have
totally irrelevant conversations for 15
minutes and waste everybody's time. Shut
the [__] up.
>> Okay, but that wasn't sandbagging Hutch.
That wasn't
>> Get your dumb ass out of here, man.
>> Why would I want to do that?
>> Get your dumb ass over here. Why would I
want to protect a community that isn't
my own whose conduct I don't want to um
comment on for reasons because I don't
want to com on the entire thing that
everyone should understand which is
reasonable. It's not unreasonable.
Why would I want to protect them
specifically? I think the thing you're
getting caught up in that most people
are going to be annoyed about is there's
like really egregious
harm being perpetrated by like the
person at the heart of the thing you
don't want to talk about. And people
probably want a way to talk about that
harm that's being like consistently
doled out without talking about the
case.
And I think that's possible and it feels
like a copout. And I don't like I don't
have criticism for Pisco because
literally everybody else is doing this
and it is just the easier way to not
catch people's eye and it's the easier
way to not get in like not get into the
line of fire yourself. But like
unfortunately I just have to be like no
you actually can discuss the doxing
stuff entirely without even having to
reference the case. You can reference
the case in the abstract. You can
actually deal with all of the doxing
allegations without the case. And I
think it's cope to just let the people
who are perpetually like who just said
they're going to greenlight your server,
which I think they'll take back because
they realize they've overstretched.
They've like overextended. But like
that's the behavior that we're all going
to pretend we didn't see. And I'm just
sitting here like I feel like I'm being
gas lit a little bit. I'm just being gas
lit a little bit. I feel a little bit of
gaslighting going on. And he could say
he doesn't want to analyze that, but
then he's like perfectly willing to talk
to Destiny. And I'm like, well, seems
like there's some morally reprehensible
behavior going on. They green lit Pisco.
You didn't see the clip from this
morning? Wait, did we not even cover
that clip from this morning? We covered
it with the spider stuff. I guess I just
didn't point it out because I've seen it
a couple times already. Give me a
second. Um, give me a second. Where's
I'm looking for a DM. It was this clip.
Maybe we didn't get here with Spider
>> I think we did
>> like you or
>> At this point actually I just I don't
care what happens to any of these
communities like peace goes included. I
think that all you guys are weird and
need to be wiped from the internet. I
think it's all like gotten way out of
hand. I'm like at this point I don't
give a [__] about any of it. Like that's
just openly greenlighting the exact same
tactics on Pisco. Yeah, we did see this.
I just I don't think I pointed it out.
Didn't hit as hard because I've seen it
a couple times anyway. So yeah, they
they did. Super cool. Um, Destiny will
take that back because he's a he's got
no balls. He just says these things and
then takes them back.
You guys should you guys should actually
do this to Pisco's community, too. Um,
actually, um, no, I misspoke. Didn't
misspeak. Lily upset.
So, I I kind of get why Pisco, but like
that's what makes it feel to me. And
he's not, you know, it's not um it's not
incumbent on him to take on that burden
of like litigating this at all. It just
feels like he's probably the only person
with the balls, too. And he just opted
out. It feels we're not going to discuss
Destiny's drama. Yeah. Well, he's like
actively trying to cut my throat.
Actually trying to cut my community's
throat, man.
And in a way that I'm not comfortable
fighting back in. I don't want to do
that. I don't want to go there. I'm not
going to make him correct by becoming
unhinged and try to do the same [__] he
does. [__] that.
>> For like the nothing money.
>> Why? and [__] up my relationship with my
actual co-hosts for no reason.
>> I don't want to do that. And yet, in
light of an honest agreement among
individuals, among me and Hutch, among
perhaps communities of my own, it gets
to that level. No, it's not your actual
opinion. You're lying. Think about that.
You're lying. It's not your real
opinion. You don't actually hold to
this. In other words, you are being
deceitful consciously. You're leading
your audience to believe a certain
thing. And you're doing so because you
want to. You have an
>> Someone just linked me the uh the Wick
panel was like, "Hey, did you see this?
Is crazy." Like, did I see it? I was on
that
>> serious purpose. Had a serious purpose
is to protect a community
>> there
>> who was intent on harassing a young
woman
>> who I don't know
>> intent on harassing literally happened
months ago. Everybody said it was weird.
Don't do that. And then basically was
like, but calling it like harassment
threats is crazy.
Like obviously specifically from
somebody applying a standard that they
don't adhere to whatsoever
>> based on nothing but bambi eyed
naively
I addressed the criticism. Okay. Can you
explain where you're getting that
opinion from? Anybody you know come on.
Not people from Snark communities,
people from Destiny's community.
This guy DRTZ. Come on. Tell me what I'm
missing.
>> Oh, here we go.
>> Talk to me. Tell me what is something
wrong? What's what's happening? Do you
think I'm lying here? Do you think I'm
being honest?
Endless Discord chats. You can see what
I'm I'm typing. You can follow along.
It's all done in the open. Endless
Twitter DMs. What's your opinion on
this? Aren't you being hypocritical?
Responding to them,
taking the time. That's not my actual
opinion. My I've always thought this.
Oh, what about this case? Doesn't this
case Harper and Row? It says good faith.
So, does that undermine your point about
No, this is why it doesn't do it.
running running cases down where there
there was one person who said well here
it says that they said like this was
designed to be uh a market substitute.
So clearly design and purpose plays into
factor 4. No, because look at this
filing where they're actually analyzing
the factor. Yes, the language appears,
you know, that they're taking into
account design and purpose, but that's
not actually what the court found. The
court was looking at objective factors
there. And so this is not distinguishing
it. This is, you know, the language is
fast and loose. It's speaking about
design and purpose from an objective
sense, not from a subjective sense. you
know, so many different objections that
have been raised that you guys don't
even know about on threads you guys
haven't seen that have 10 viewers. And
that was the context of yesterday's
conversation. So yesterday after five
hours of talking to you guys just don't
know about the 10 viewer threads on
Twitter. Okay.
>> Not a snark.
>> Pisco got Pisco got banned you ain't
never heard of, bro. Okay, it's over.
>> The head mod of Destiny's community. He
he has an entire effort post. He says,
"Pisco, just be normal. Just be normal
when you're encountering normal people."
I read the post. I say, he says, I don't
think he'll talk to me about this. I
say, 'Yes, I'll talk to this. I'll talk
with this with you about this. I'll talk
to you for and we did so in front of
everybody for 4 hours.
And you can disagree with my approach in
that conversation. You can't say I
didn't I don't have the the desire to to
actually sus it out. I could be doing
more interesting things regardless of
whether or not, you know, it's
necessarily more money on the margin.
things that I would enjoy more not that
I don't enjoy like going in and now you
know I I get some sort of individual
enjoyment out of that in terms of the
>> this guy was about to say he's not a
debate that's
>> topic itself it's losing
>> like I people could call Pisco a debate
and it's like true Pisco clearly gets
off unironically on believing he's
totally correct and everyone like a huge
mob of people want to tell him he's
wrong he's clearly never been happier in
his entire life than in those moments
but that doesn't in and of itself make
him wrong. In fact, I believe he's
obviously correct in these situations,
but like I like he's supposed to say
like I don't get anything out of well I
get a little I do get a little bit out
of it now subs are saying what
>> wait which pause frame
>> things that I would enjoy more not that
I don't enjoy like going in and now you
know I I get some sort of individual
enjoyment out of that one
>> that one was crazy
>> things that I would enjoy more not that
I don't enjoy like going and now and now
you know I get some sort of individual
enjoyment out of that in terms of the
topic itself it's losing me subs it's
people are saying what the [__] why are
you spending this much time on it it's
boring so why am I doing it? Why am I
spending 4 hours talking to the head mod
who made this effort post saying be more
normal? Is it because I'm bad faith?
It's in that context. And then there's a
follow-up that night yesterday. So that
that conversation happened like two days
ago. Then he messages me in the Discord
and says, you know, these are these are
the thoughts and you know, and I respond
to him in text and you guys can all see
the responses in the text. He says, why
don't you hop into a VC? It's like,
okay. In the moment, it's 11:00 at
night. I um um this DJ asked Pisco to
talk and Pisco said yes. And then
Snarkers hopped in and so Pisco is now
best friends with Queen and Jtock and
he's also good friends with Dickers and
this is really dumb. This guy's such a
snarker. See his message. I say sure,
pop it to talk to a Destiny mod. The
head mod or at least I think he's head
mod. Most important mod, not a snarker.
Yeah, I just got to go without
triggering me again so I can finish this
VOD. Holy [__]
>> And we talk. I don't agree with his
opinion. I think it's ridiculous. I
think what he's saying doesn't make any
sense. I've always maintained that. If I
was convinced by it, I would say it. I'm
not convinced. I don't find it
convincing. I think it's stupid. But I'm
engaging with it because I want to talk
to see what am I missing.
Taking it at its strongest.
>> Uh, I'm so glad. Tell me. Tell me
somebody was recording that VC last
night when this guy's voice cracked.
Okay. I don't think I've ever heard a
more cataclysmous cataclysmic voice
crack than I heard last night from
Quean. Okay, that [__] was crazy.
And then he's going to come out here and
try to talk. Get the out of here.
Need that for the compilation. You have
no idea, FP. It was funny cuz we were
checking people who were coming in with
like brand new accounts. We're just
like, "Hey, just mic up. Say something
so we know who you are." And then we
voice cracked and I'm just like, dude, I
hope somebody was recording. Actually, I
hope somebody's recording this whole
conversation because that can't not have
been recorded. That would be disastrous
if we missed that. Dude, I get it. You
stream so much. Like my voice is Yeah.
Yeah, dude. When you stream like eight
hours a day, like literally seven days a
week for like weeks on end, eventually
you're using your voice so much that
it's just going to start like breaking.
I feel like I'm moments away from
probably never be that bad, but okay.
All right. Please from everybody,
>> please finish. I'm like actually so
tired already and I just
>> I'm not even tired. Like I got to go to
sleep. It's just like at the end of an
eight hour stream like you're just kind
of fried a little bit. I want to go
chill. Can I go chill?
>> Loner box. He's not a non debate. He's a
debater.
>> Yeah, lonerbox debater.
>> And you can take issue with how that
conversation is run. Oh wow. It took
this long because you're doing that. I
totally disagree with that. But you
can't say it's motivated by like malice.
What do I get out of that? I'm going to
get tea. Um,
>> I think I'm exposed as a as a hypocrite.
When you listen to those convers I truly
challenge you to break apart a lot of
these conversations and see who you
think is uh trying to
>> It's not even my social battery running
dry. Honestly, if I I think Pisco's kind
of got it cased. I like the idea of like
getting up streaming for 4 hours and
then like doing something else for a
little bit, chilling and then coming
back collecting like a little more
content and then doing another four
hours. I think Pisco does that quite a
bit where he'll come on in the morning,
he'll do like a morning segment, and
then he'll take a break and he'll do an
evening segment. I I really like that
idea. I think it's kind of cool. I'm
thinking about it. I'm thinking about
doing something like that to be honest
with you. I would have to be getting up
way earlier, right? And then you could
just you I think it lets you create like
a cadence where your community is like
always active.
>> We'll see. Slow down.
>> We'll see. We'll see. And then also
another member members of the community
come to listen to me as it as is their
right to do as a member of the server
right here meaning a privilege as being
a member of the server. You know they
are a member of the ser the server in
good standing in that what in that they
violate the rules of the server and so
we're an open channel where they're
allowed to be not allowed to record.
Okay that's against the rule but they're
allowed to be in the server. They're
allowed to be in a Okay, that's against
the rule. Were there a lot of me?
>> I caught this one as we were going by
and I was like, "Okay, that's another
one. That's another one
100%."
>> The server.
>> Good stuff.
>> VC,
>> a VC that was, you know, created for
specific all kinds of crazy faces. You
love
>> addressing concerns from Destiny's
community, from Destiny's top mod. And
what what was the response to that?
What was the response,
>> bro? I LIKE I'M LIKE 30 MINUTES OFF
SCHEDULE and you guys freak the out.
Thank god that I'm not entertaining as
Fentes. That guy goes like 5 hours off
schedule and people don't complain.
Okay. Or they complain but like he
doesn't care anyway. But holy sh I'm
like 30 minutes late. You guys are like
this guy can't even keep a schedule.
This guy's the least responsible
streamer ever. Mother of God was the
response. Oh look Pisco. You know he's
crazy. He's wrong. But at least he's
hearing the argument out. You know,
Hobbit messages him and he's willing to
have the conversation. He's not like one
of these cowards who won't.
He's not like one of these cowards who
won't have the conversation. More than I
can say for them at 11:00. Not even.
>> Why don't we have the Darius star in
here? That's a good question. Uh, it's
cuz I can't delegate other people to
Adams and then I didn't think to add it
myself.
>> Streaming, right? No financial motiv. I
don't know who the [__] is going to join
the [__] PC. I'm on my phone laying
down on my bed and what was the response
to that?
>> What was the response?
I need to wake up earlier.
>> Taking the time to address concerns from
the Destiny community as expressed by
Destiny's head Reddit mod as expressed
by a member in good stand of that
community, Zip Zip. What was the
response to that? Was that a point in my
favor? No. Why was it not a point in my
favor? The fact I did that, it was more
evidence against me. Why was it more
evidence against me? Well, because there
were snarkers that showed up in the VC.
That proves the point. That proves the
point. That proves what we've been
saying. because they showed up in a VC
where they have access to the VC because
I where I couldn't have predicted. I did
I ping them? No, I didn't [__] ping
them. Maybe someone told them. I can't
control what they [__] DM'd each
other, but they haven't broken server
rules. Not that I know of. Maybe they
have. If you bring it to our attention,
we will assess it. But where they have a
right to be someone started violating
the rules? Who violated the rules?
Whoever was re I don't even know. We're
going to take a look at it. Whoever was
restreaming, someone showed that someone
was restreaming it. That was breaking my
rules because there's a rule. We don't
want people to stream the VCs without
people knowing about it. I don't want
that to happen. But someone was
rereaming it, weren't they? And I have a
suspicion about where that rule breaking
came from. And you do, too. So, what's
going on here? So, my rules don't matter
to a community. I'm specifically in the
VC who address concerns from that
community, from people who are in good
standing, and who are equipped to be
able to present the arguments in their
strongest form. And because snarkers
anti fans are in the VC, I am condemned
as myself a snarker. An anti-fan.
>> Oh, the other stuff I think is at his
childhood home. Simpo. I think that's
like his childhood bedroom or something
he was saying. So like that's his old
setup or whatever. His old computer and
he's not updating it cuz I don't think
he spends very much time there. So like
goes home to and he streams from there.
So it's like a totally different. This
is his house or his apartment condo.
Whatever the idea doesn't matter. No
VCs. So, here's the thing. My VCs are
for my community. You want to make
content out of it, there's a streamable
VC, right?
There's a streamable VC. You want to
stream something, you want to record
something, you can go to the streamable
VC where it's clear for everybody who's
in there that this is live, that you
could be recorded, this is okay to
record in here. You go to like the the
community VCs where people having
community conversations and you make
content out of it. Keep yourself banned.
Get the [__] out of here. It doesn't
matter. What doesn't matter is this
Bambi like naive approach in which well
if we just convince them cuz it's not
about that. It's never been about that.
If the situation with Ethan Klein
lawsuit were completely reversed 95% of
people's perspectives would be
completely reversed.
Everyone knows it. I can't appeal to
anything other than your gut in this
moment. Everyone's positions 95% not
mine would be exactly the opposite.
So it's not about them on my argument.
It's not on the specific question of
whether I'm good faith or bad faith. I'm
so glad that Pisco had a conversation
with Zip Zip and Zip Zip was such bad
faith in the conversation that it
blackpiled him and he's like actually
all of these people are total cultists
and they literally can't they literally
can't think for themselves and if this
was done in reverse they'd have the
exact opposite opinion because they are
cultlike.
>> It's not about whether I'm willing to
hear the criticism.
>> No, it's obvious DG was recording. DG
was openly like streaming it in DGG
chat.
>> Spend time specifically to address it.
It's not about that. Not about what I
say. It's
>> Stop BC and you're condemned.
>> I'm still
>> a terrorist. Putting aside the absurd
>> how's it going?
>> Uh, decent dude. It actually takes so
long to get through. I get like so
annoyed at this content.
>> Like going back to like maybe an hour
day of day of this tops cuz I could
literally sit here and just like rant
angrily for like 20 minutes every time I
stop. Takes forever, dude.
>> Yeah. I I I don't have, you know, I can
do I can repeat myself for the hundth
time on the same contradictions
>> a lot of the time.
>> These specific contradictions and this
specific drama at this point I run that
course,
>> you know.
>> Um, a little bit. You're cutting out
just a little bit by the way, but um
>> I I need
>> Yep. Um, dude, the uh Oh, I love
discussing the like um the melancholic
situation Zip Zip must have been in
where like you you talk like three times
in that VC and each time Zip Zip got to
witness you get something he's never
gotten like the streamer that he loves
and adores just being like, "Yeah, that
guy that what that guy just said is
correct." Like Pisco not knowing you and
you're like, "Wait, no, what?" He's
like, "No, wait. Whatever that guy that
guy who just spoke, that guy was
correct. He's got it." sitting there
like never says I've got it.
>> Just argues with me.
>> It's like so rough. Uh
>> yeah, I just ordered my um mic. So tell
me if I cut out again a clip or whatever
the
>> No, it sounds about back to normal.
Sounds like how it should be.
>> Yeah, cool.
>> Seems that way.
>> Sweet, sweet, sweet.
>> Of course it's a screen share.
>> Yeah. Yeah. I'm about to finish up this
Pisco thing. I'm like at the hour mark
of his stream or whatever. I just want
to cover his [__] I think there's like
parts of this that are cope, but they're
like not cope in ways that like he's
actually coping and he's like
disingenuous. Like I I think I think
what he's doing like banning all this
conversation, that's probably the
highest money-making path he could take
long term, just building around his
community. Um because I think if he
tries to engage with the DGers, this
just won't work. and
and like they're ba basically he's
trying to appease people who
whose sense of right and wrong is just
based on what Destiny says. So whenever
Destiny says Pisco's wrong, Pisco would
be wrong to them and they'll never be
able to drop it. This is like not
actually worth it. So actually like
blocking all of it out is probably the
highest value thing he can do. And yet
at the same time it's kind of annoying
because I think that's exactly why
Destiny went and talked about his drama
with people in Pisco's Discord for like
four hours last night which we also got
blamed for by the way
>> like basically like why did Jtock and
Queen discuss like Destiny drama and I'm
like bro some you mentioned you left
before me and the second someone
mentioned Destiny I disconnected
immediately went to my VC and start a VC
there. Yeah,
Discord
>> when I was when I was talking. I wasn't
bringing up Destiny, you know, it was
sort of like um
>> it was tangentially
involved cuz Pisco was throwing out like
little examples and that that had like
little relevance and and
>> yeah,
>> but yeah, there was no um there's no
like, oh, let's let's talk about the
Destiny drama, guys. Let's let's sit
around and talk about how
>> this guy's a hate him.
>> I know you said that. Zip Zip wanted to
hear that he off on car door handles or
whatever. But what he really wanted was
people to like try to press him on
Destiny stuff. That's what he wanted
more than anything, right?
>> Yeah.
>> Just say, "Oh, these guys are trauma
farmers. They're just they're just here
for drama. They don't care. You just
press them on the pisco conversation
then peeled out." Gross.
>> Yeah. I mean, why I didn't join to like
um you know, go and say, "Oh, isn't
Destiny so evil? It was I joined cuz I
wanted to have peace. go talk about
the Ethan Klein stuff, you know,
independent of Destiny, cuz you know,
there are some thoughts that
people have that are that are totally
independent of of of Destiny's
existence, much to his disappointment, I
think.
>> Yeah. Yeah. I just want Yeah, I just
want to chill listen to that while I was
like playing Civ. And I was I was also
interested cuz somebody told me that he
was tearing a strip out of Zip Zip and I
was like, "Oh, that sounds funny as let
me go hop in there."
>> Yeah. I mean, that that was that was
after I've been in there for a while, I
think, by the time someone was telling
you that probably. So, cuz uh that I
didn't quite pick up until a little bit
in.
>> Jade asked, "Is Destiny irrelevant yet?"
Um, I mean, it seems like it's getting
there, but also not get I don't know. I
don't know. He seems to spend a lot of
his waking hours thinking about how he
can finally wipe out a 400 viewer kick
streamer. So, probably for as long as
he's going to have that as his main
focus, going to be difficult to make
compelling content. You know what I'm
saying? You know what I'm saying? Give
me a play. It looks ridiculous that
anyone can say it out loud. I'm naive
enough to thought to think that anyone
ever cared for the standard at all or a
standard or anything.
>> Oh, also,
um I'm actively asking people for the
recording that voice crack last night to
reply to your fat joke on Twitter. Okay,
just so you know.
>> No longer drama related to Ethan Klein
post anywhere banned.
>> No, no, no, no. That was in my Discord.
Unlucky.
>> Oh, [__] He kicked us out
>> in the server. There may be and just to
out there, there can be occasion
potentially where I might address stuff,
you know, if if it comes up, if for
whatever reason, you know, Dan Saltman
wants to have a conversation with me in
which the, you know, it's all done and
openly on the live stream. That is the
one exception. And then you know you can
chat if it's like responsive to stuff
that's going on. But in terms of the
server done and that is
>> depressing.
>> Um yeah I was sort of like
>> I half watched it. I was playing games
and making food while I watched it but
yeah.
>> Oh yeah. Um
yeah I went on there. I was like I have
no interest talking to Destiny.
>> Dude, I'm sorry. I need to just lay out
one t one time on on your stream as
well. I did not dog the Drazzi. I have
never dark sell the Drazzi. The argument
for doxing there is incredibly tenuous.
It was not on one profile. It was on
three profiles. It was not just on his
PayPal. It was on his Tik Tok and his
Instagram as his username. His full name
as his username and his handle as Elder
Drazzi on three different platforms all
over the place. no reason to believe it
was private and all people did was make
puns with his name and then when he was
upset with it, help him take it down.
That's and that's what everyone's upset
about and calling a horrible doxing that
has to follow, you know, anyone that was
tangentially related to Ch's community
for another
>> I just three years.
>> I feel like all you got to do is just
see how Drazzy feels about it. And it's
like I looked at it as like Drazzie
played Street Fighter when Street
Fighter 6 released with like everybody
in spicy chat. I don't think he'd do
that with the people who like doxed him
in
>> take it right back to what happened. He
was not upset about the doxing. That was
not what he was upset about. That is
something that Stardust and Wick and
these champions. But fundamentally what
he was actually upset about and they
fudged the details because they wanted
to jump on this even though he had said
this multiple times and whatever. um was
the and then they used the fact that he
said, "Oh yeah, I guess I care about the
doxing." But really they used that to
say, "Oh, no, he does care about the
quoteunquote doxing." What he was really
what they he was really upset about was
the fact that he had done or his ex wife
and ex-girlfriend who was still his wife
at that point I think had done that he's
a polygill um had done photo shoots
together only fans photo shoots together
or something and it was like tagged
tagged BBW and we had you know mocked
those and that that's he had liked that
stuff on his main account and all this
[__] was like all populated on his main
feeds but that's what he was really
upset about was that that had been
mocked. Uh these images have been pulled
up and mocked. Obviously, I won't pull
them up or you make huge reference to
them here, but that that is what was
really upsetting. He said that's what
upset him and it it wasn't so much
>> and yeah.
So, so I I hate I hate the fact that
they constantly still bring up
>> everybody bring that up.
>> I don't laugh at the BBW tag,
>> which you can imagine sort of like how,
you know, it's Elder Drazy's wife with a
BB. I just You can't do that on your
main content creator profile and and
then be like, you can't make fun of
that, you know, in my opinion.
>> Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Well, dude, I agree
with you entirely. I'm just I'm sitting
here. I'm like, "Dude, I we should just
move on." I feel I feel like secondhand
embarrassment just hearing about that
story. I'm like, "Dude, that's that's
rough. That's Jesus Christ, man."
>> I mean, the other Drazi stories don't
get any better, so I mean Yeah. Yeah.
Okay. All right.
Okay. All right. Um,
what else was there? Doobie versus
Destiny. I thought Doobie, Dude, I don't
know why. Why would Destiny go join and
like go over these logs? Dude, these
logs actually seem so much worse.
>> Made classic error of staking literally
anything on Lauren de Laguna ever.
>> That is the biggest problem.
>> I know.
>> I know that conversation.
>> I don't even think like Lauren de Laguna
like lies about everything. I don't
think she's like totally insane. I like,
you know, I don't trust anything going
on with cuz she, you know,
>> it's the whole I don't trust any of it.
I don't want to, you know, pass through
it all. It's impossible. I don't care.
And
>> and like um Destiny unfortunately like
you you can not up and Destiny will make
up. It's like if you actually bet it on
Lauren de Laguna and there's a [__]
there. It's like yeah, it's
so this is dude there's like I can't
believe Willie Mack let himself get
scoped on this dude. Why do you have
saved? And then Desi responds with
multiple reasons why it's okay to save.
And then he's like, "You're absolutely
insane for saying that I have child my
computer."
>> When legitimately under 18 when these
were taken, so these are these. What's
the object?
>> Yeah, exactly. object.
>> If something were to come out of this, I
don't know if um
>> the white head
>> if hypothetically her
>> her boyfriend or whatever was actually
trafficking or getting other dudes on
video for him for some kind of
investigation for like it's other dudes
on video for him. So So what are you
saying there? You're implying that these
guys could be identified from the
material material you have doing acts
and it seems to be cuz that's what you
would want to preserve to be able to
prove that these guys are a child and
who they are. You would need you would
assumely you're saying you are keeping
that right. It just it doesn't
>> make any sense to read this in any way
other than I have it right now. That's
what that's what every aspect of these
messages reads as.
>> And you literally say, "No, that's not
what happened." And there are people
who believe that.
>> Yeah.
>> Like,
>> bro, there are people in the chat and
like not even Oh, how do I explain it?
They're like people in the Wick chat who
are like, "Oh, I didn't even realize you
could read it two ways." Like, what's
the second way? What's the second way?
>> Okay. All right. Yeah, I Doobie almost I
thought Dubbie was going to move on
without reading the this page of logs
and he didn't even get to read it very
much. Like this is why I honestly I do
believe there's just no reason if you're
talking about Destiny's allegations to
have a like real time conversation with
him. I said like I would go
>> that's what I've always said is like you
cannot try and argue with Destiny on
like his personal life because he is
like so willing to um play the ambiguity
or just make facts up but yeah it has to
be a topic of which there is like
perfect knowledge or at least perfect
knowledge to be able to prove um the
claims where even if some contradictory
piece of information was brought up uh
that just like totally made up the point
still stands you know
>> well and I mean I would argue with him
like over Twitter or something. You know
what I mean? Like I I think like
asynchronous
as in like I I don't have to sit here.
It's not like it's like when the moment
dude
no
me. Yeah. Yeah. where you could just
like lay out this and like point it out
and then he would have to actually argue
against your whole argument and it can't
be done, right? He knows if you lay out
your whole argument like it's over.
There's no you can't make a counter to
this.
>> Oh, it was a whole piece of
conversation. Lally that whole piece of
conversation was him desperately trying
to stop Pisco from weighing out any of
his arguments in full. Uh,
dude. Oh, somebody in chat just said
even Willie understood in DMs. Pro
understood in the DMs. Possibly just to
trigger me because I'm like, dude,
Willie Mack actually let himself get gas
lit into thinking like he might have
been wrong here. Like Willie Mack has no
internal monologue. Like somebody was
like, "You just made this up about
Destiny." He's like,
>> Mac is about
>> born cattle. He is just born to be, you
know, in in the in chains.
>> It's so crazy
>> being, you know, whipped and picking
cotton.
>> Do not criticize Israel.
>> God. H. Okay.
Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Okay. I think we're
almost getting to the end of this Pisco
thing. I'm trying to think of Oh, the
other thing I didn't really like is he's
like, "Well, I don't want to." He He has
this topic, which is the Pixie case.
>> What's that? You're a You ban him out.
>> I said I'd ban him until I could like uh
listen to the clip. I was like, "Oh,
I'll ban him if you feel unsafe. Then
I'm going to go listen to the clip."
>> There ain't no way you listen that clip
and you're like, "This guy should be
banned." There is actually zero. There
are no way.
>> I let him lay it out, right?
>> I let him lay it out and I'm like, "This
is what I heard." And then he was like,
"Yeah, I was really threatening."
>> Like he's going to show up on your
doorstep and watch the video and he
can't even like say it. He's like, He
said he was putting together.
>> I don't want to say it because as if as
if like revealed some piece of
information and stuff he was saying his
oh. So he said something that clued you
into. It's like no he just doesn't want
to say it because it sounds ridiculous
if he gets on stream and says
>> yeah I felt genuinely threatened when
this guy said that I'm a and he's going
to show up to my house and show me a
video of me a 14year-old girl. I was
really scared when he said that. No you
come. Unless you are literally a Why
would you be scared of that? Why would
you think he's being serious?
>> Yeah. No, I It's just one of those
things where the none of these these
people are always going to say the thing
they think like hurts you the most,
right? Like they it's like a war to them
and they will not be honest. They can
lie as long as they l they feel like
their life is basically on the line. So
that they're like they would just do
whatever. They just like you know
operate on the same survival mechanism
that the you know hero does. Wild. All
right, one sec. I got to replay it a
couple pig.
>> Dung Devil donated $3. I think the real
reason Destiny didn't hand in the
dossier he said he was putting together
is that he was advised not to because he
was hoarding so much that he couldn't
not get in trouble for it. Never mind
his offer to fly out to
>> messaged me like, "Oh,
>> that's not a bad That's not a bad
theory." Yeah. No, but that's not a bad
theory. The guy Dung Devil says that he
feels like pro probably what actually
happened is he laid up like a
hypothetical for Andy B where he's like
hypothetically if I was holding on to
some stuff some images of a minor. Um
should I go to the cops with them? And
Andy B was probably like well
hypothetically if you were warned you
could get in a lot of trouble. So
hypothetically you probably shouldn't go
to the cops with any of that stuff.
>> I feel like I possible
>> um I think they would probably
>> I don't even think that would happen.
Here's my mind palace interpretation of
conversation.
He says,
uh, oh, you know, hypothetical, my other
stuff. And basically Andy B will just
lay out the law very clearly and say,
mitigate liability to yourself. That's
from everything I heard, all lawyers,
everything I looked up at the time of
this happening is it would basically be
that because they can't like there's
there's a lot of rules around not being
able to, you know, say like delete
evidence, some that, right? So they they
just like when there's like a conflict
like that where there could be multiple
insecting things responsibilities to
kind of cut against each other and you
could get yourself in trouble. I think
they usually say basically like you know
here here's your situation and you
should do what's best for you. Um, dude,
I I sure hope that like dude, it's so up
that there's a government that would be
totally willing to prosecute this guy on
this one on this thing. And Cash Patel
is the lead investigator, the the head
of the FBI for sure.
>> Yeah, guys, guys, it's okay. We're
getting investigate, guys. Cash Patel
said that he's going to throw the book
at this guy. God damn it.
Uh,
>> what a world. Yeah, I think and here's
the thing.
I'm like at this point based on
everything Destiny said, I'm pretty sure
that that that whatever email that got
posted on Kiwi Farms that was basically
like here's the group chat that I had. I
felt really uncomfortable told me he had
to blow the genitals cuz why are you
doing that? I'm pretty confident he
straight up just threw in that. Like
like realistically I'm not going to go
claim that and say like tell other
people to do that argument. But it's
like balance of probability
>> in the back of my head. Yeah, the back
of my head that's absolutely my heart is
there. That's where my heart is. the
fact that he's like never once um tried
to deny it. Like he he literally has
confirmed that the group chat existed,
right? That they were trying to find
Rose and he confirmed it after it was
first exposed through that email.
>> So I don't know like if there were a law
enforcement body looking into this and
they looked through his Discord logs.
Feels like he's basically
I don't understand. You're not hooped at
that point, but
you know, it is what it is. I'm not a
lawyer. Not a lawyer at Um, oh yeah, I
was going to say moral messaged me after
you banned him um on stream or whatever.
And then he he messaged me and said
like,
"Oh, you know, if you have to ban me,
that that's fine. You have to ban me
that's fine. I understand. I make
everyone look bad." He's like the most,
you know,
>> why didn't he message?
>> I don't I'm like your server. He's
already server. He was like, "Should I
should I just leave your server? I don't
I don't want to make it look bad.
No, I like I understand the humor he was
going for. I'm like, "Oh yeah, I know
exactly like what you'd be talking about
here. I haven't heard it, but like I'm
pretty sure he did some crazy." And then
somebody was like, "This is what he
said." Like this is what he said. You
think that was serious? And he's like,
"Yeah, I felt really threatened."
>> When we first started, well, when I
first started, you know, talking to War
was watching that Vi
where he's like saying VC saying you,
you know, what was it?
>> You got
Yeah. Yeah. That was it. Exactly.
It's like what you like, yeah, I
understand. I get it. It's a [__]
joke. No one's, you know, it's only Zip
Zip who is even, you know, plausible
that anyone could believe. It's only
plausible that Zip Zip could believe it
because that guy is so,
>> you know, literally anyone else. And I
feel like
>> but like realistically if we ask Zip Zip
so now that you've taken that position
on morale given he has no history of
doxing has never doxed anybody isn't
accused of doxing anybody what do you
think of Destiny saying he wants
somebody to J and Queenman after doxing
Jtock and Queen or
he doesn't have a position on that. No
he doesn't have a position on that.
>> He doesn't Yeah. I guess he's just
neutral. He's just neutral in that one
guys. It's like, dude, actually,
>> and the the disingenuous like standard
thing, I'm gonna apply this standard to
you that I'd never apply to myself.
That's actually where I'm at. It's like
I see it's just every single time like
literally if you if you actually believe
this, if you actually believe was a
problem, you wouldn't be watching
Destiny. You wouldn't be capable of
having this conversation because you
wouldn't exist in this space right now
if you actually had this problem is so
disingenuous,
but
whatever. All right, I'm gonna try to
finish up this video. There's a
soundboard of VC called Mau Grape that
is fitting right now. Well, that is the
that is the thing, but it's it's
censored, which is
I wanted to get the uncensored version
of it. Me, I'll play it for people
though, so they can hear it.
>> Shut the [__] up.
>> Yeah. It's not a rule that anyone else,
>> no one else gets that benefit. No one
else gets a we don't talk about their
bad rule, but in the interest of at a
bare minimum lowering my level of
annoyance having to feel this my
interest, a special little rule for two
special little communities.
>> This was good.
>> No drama discussion on mine about those
two streamers.
>> If you want to do that, do it somewhere
else. I don't want to see it. I think
technically this means that if somebody
accuses me of being a doctor, I still
get to litigate that in Pisco server,
right?
>> Why would you want to, man? Why would
you want to? Why do you care to?
>> Why would I want to? Um cuz it the
people coming on my server, the people
joining my stream. I like running a
collaborative stream from time to time.
>> But you don't get like you're not, you
know, you don't make any progress on
that by arguing in Pisco server. No, I
mean I'm probably not going to, but I
will say basically what I did before
when um I think Destiny was trying to
bait me into talking [__] about him to
try to get me banned. I just messaged
the mods. I'm like, "Hey, can I respond
to that?" I just accept that uh you
know, in the
Jim Crow world that is Pisco Server, I
get to use the colored only.
>> It's like being Palestinian, man. It's
It's legit like being Palestinian. It's
like so [__] up.
>> Yeah. Yep.
Different standards for different colors
of folks.
It is the way it is. Yeah. Anyway, it's
Oh, boy.
>> And with that, folks, we have some
content. We got another like hour so
y'all can chill or not.
>> He just leeches the Gondam and Gilmore
podcast. God damn.
It's funny teachers are like, "Wow,
there's so many Jtock and Queen people
here. Clearly, they try to mind control
Pisco when there's like 95% DGers there.
Um, it started hitting like a point
where at least in the YouTube chat, I
think it was getting to like 50/50 for a
while. Um, I'd say the actual Pisco
viewers are people who are from who are
more left-leaning and maybe, you know,
like that somebody was being honest
about the Ethan lawsuit, right?
I would say there's a good chunk of like
the YouTube chat, some kick chatters.
So I I don't think it's like crazy there
in his discord. It is a lot of DGs,
but I don't think it's like I don't
think it's like crazy to say that there
are some people and I wish because I
know a lot of the names. I I wish people
weren't so pushy some of the left laning
people, but they are like a lot of the
time. So it is what it is. What can you
do?
>> Maybe it's not bad to have
>> Yeah, you got like they're like the
counterbalance to DG. So, it's like hard
to be too mad about it. Let's just be
honest, man. His chat is communist
Marxist Leninist.
That is what the DJers say. Yes,
communist Marxist Leninist. Eh, hold on
a second. What is this? I should get
sent a picture.
Probably a correct comment. Okay, we'll
see where it goes. I'd say right off the
bat, it looks correct. Mr. Girl,
continual vindication. Destiny centering
the attention towards Pisco's community
and how Pisco has to moderate. ban
everyone who doesn't like Destiny and
voices it from the chat and constantly
said you only think this because of
obsessive crazy bad actors in your like
Jtock Queen Aaron and Doobie and how he
has to cut those people off. This is the
same tactics Mr. Girl called out years
ago. If any portion of vas of a vassal
community of destinies starts to garner
any amount of people that don't like
him, he has to give the that orbiter the
talk where he undermines their ability
to think for themselves, loads them with
talking points, and tries to convince
them that everyone and anyone leveraging
any criticism about him are crazy,
insane, bad faith actors, and that none
of the critiques/reasons to not like him
are true and are completely BS. critical
element here are certain people, certain
talentless hack losers like
counterpoints in Arerodite who will do
this and pretend, oh, I'm just like a
nice person who, you know, I get to have
private conversations with Destiny. He's
actually really nice. And this JTO guy
lies about him and he lies about me and
he lies about everybody and he's like
the worst and you just should just
believe me and I'm just like woo I'm
just like a little old I I just couldn't
possibly defend myself.
Very important to have the good cop bad
cop elements there. Okay, critical. In
fact, how am I figuring this out? Um,
mostly, you know, schizosphere tap in,
but it it has happened guaranteed. I
know Pisco will watch this VOD as he
watched the previous VOD and he will
understand this. He'll he'll know what
I'm talking about. When when they come
to you and they're like, "This Jtock guy
is actually evil. Have you heard the he
said about me? Have you have you seen
He's like threatened me. He's like
threatened my family. Like we got
doxed." I know this has happened. I
promise you this happened. Okay, Pisco,
just ask for evidence of any of it.
anything that attributes it to me,
please in the future when it does
happen.
Anyway, I think we finished with the
Pisco stuff. I That was all the content
I was going to do today. I could do more
[__] but I'm probably going to hop off
and uh I don't know, chill for a little
bit. I might hop in the Discord a little
bit. We'll see. Getting a little late,
but we'll we'll see what's going on.
Could hop in the Discord, check some
stuff out. All right,
stream. Be back tomorrow, I believe.
Yeah. Yeah, I'll be back tomorrow. Yeah,
I don't know what I'm doing for
Christmas. I'm like going home. I don't
know if I'm going to take my laptop and
stream. If I want to take my laptop and
stream, I have to like start setting my
laptop up now. So, maybe I'll just do
that. I'll set my laptop up to stream
and I'll go stream like a day or two
from home because I won't I won't have
to My parents will be tired and shoot
anyway. All right. All right. Let's see.
Nobody's really online. I'm just gonna
end. See you guys later. Have a good
night, everybody. Bye-bye.